EMERGENCY TO PROTECT PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN
HERE THE SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES.
NOT ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARING
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH SOME OF
OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY REMEMBERS
ATTENDING REMOTELY TODAY OUR
SENATORS GONZALES IN STERN.
SENATORS AS A REMINDER PLEASE
MUTE YOUR YOUR PHONES OR
COMPUTERS THIS WILL GREATLY AID
IN ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK I ASKED THAT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED THAT
YOU RAISE. YOUR HAND USING THE
FEATURE ON THE PROGRAM EACH TIME
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP
UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE.
PLEASE SELECT UNMUTE BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING R. I. T. PERSON I
WILL PUT YOU. BACK ON MUTE WHEN
YOU'RE DONE. WHAT'S RECOGNIZED
TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU
CAN BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE
YOUR NAME AND THEN. YOU'RE READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO
ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS THE PUBLIC IN
THE HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. WE'LL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY. TODAY FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT TO SPEND TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. THREE THREE SIX.
FOUR FOUR THREE SEVEN THE ACCESS
CODE IS. EIGHT TWO SIX EIGHT
FOUR TWO EIGHT. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO SENATE. INDOOR
COMMITTEE THE SENATE OR INDOOR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WE MOVED
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR DIAL ONE
THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. PLEASE PRESS THIS
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY
FOR AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. THAT TIME YOU'LL BE A
MUTED READY ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE.
IT'S IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE. MAYBE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE HEARING. SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED
. WE HAVE FIVE MEASURES ON
TODAY'S AGENDA BEFORE WE HAD A
PRESENTATION MEASURES WE'RE
GOING TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND
CHIEF COUNSEL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FOR PURPOSES OF
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM. SURE
BURKE THERE ARE A NUMBER IS HERE
A VICE CHAIR BOARD YES. VICE
CHAIR BOARD THIS IS PRESENT.
ABIERTO THE RUSSELL GONZALEZ.
PRESIDENT GONZALEZ'S PRESENT
REMOTELY HURTS BERG. JONES JONES
IS HERE LAYERED LAYERED IS HERE
STERN. STERN PRISON REMOTELY
SENATOR STERN IS PRESENT
REMOTELY A CENTER RIGHT HOUSE
SKI HERE CENTER RIGHT CASKEY IS
HERE IS SENATOR WIENER. SENATOR
WIENER IS PRESENT YOU HAVE. YOU
HAVE A QUORUM HERE PRESENT IN
THE CHAMBER. THANK YOU MA'AM
CHIEF COUNSEL- I NOTE THAT ARE
FIRST AUTHORS HERE SINNER
CORTESE CENTER CORTESE IF YOU
PREPARE THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THIS
IS ON ITEM NUMBER ONE SP FOUR
THREE FIVE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT THE SENATE BILL FOUR
THIRTY FIVE WHICH WILL CREATE A
FIRST IN THE NATION LAW TO
EMPOWER VICTIMS OF DIGITAL
TRAFFICKING TO BRING CIVIL
ACTION AGAINST. ANY PERSON OR
ONLINE PLATFORM TO DISTRIBUTE
CERTAIN SEXUAL MATERIAL THEM
WITHOUT THEIR CONSENT AND I
SHOULD ADD THE BILL IDENTIFIES-
THE VERY SPECIFIC PRESCRIBED-
THE DESCRIPTION OF WHAT'S NOT
CONSENSUAL THIS BILL STEMS FROM
A TRAGEDY. THAT TOOK PLACE IN MY
DISTRICT. BUT WERE TEENAGER TOOK
HER OWN LIFE AFTER HER
ASSAILANTS DISTRIBUTED PHOTOS OF
HER SEXUAL ASSAULT. ADDITIONALLY
THE TRAFFICKING OF DIGITAL
SEXUAL MATERIAL HAS BECOME
INCREASINGLY PERVASIVE NIGHT
NATIONWIDE. CONTENT THAT IS
UPLOADED TO THE INTERNET EACH
DAY INCLUDES RAPE CHILD RAPE
REVENGE **** AND OTHER FORMS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT. IN TWENTY TWENTY
SIXTY NINE MILLION ONLINE VIDEOS
AND OTHER CHILD SEXUAL ABUSE
MATERIAL WAS REPORTED TO FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES THE COURSE AS JUST
WHAT WAS REPORTED. IN OPINION
COLUMNIST FOR THE NEW YORK TIMES
RECENTLY PROFILED VICTIMS OF
CHILD SEXUAL ABUSE. WHO ARE
MONETIZED AND EXPLOITED THROUGH
WEBSITES THAT ALLOW THIS
MATERIAL GENERATED ADVERTISING
IMPRESSIONS FROM IT. WITHOUT
THEIR CONSENT OF WITHOUT
GUARDING CONSENT WITHOUT ANY
CONSENT ONCE THIS CONTENT IS
UPLOADED TO AN ONLINE PLATFORM
IT CAN BE DOWNLOADED BY THE
USERS OF COURSE. AND EVEN IF THE
PERFORMER REMOVE SOME MATERIAL
ANYONE WHO PREVIOUSLY DONE ALL
OF THE MATERIAL CAN SIMPLY RE
UPLOAD IT. LEADING TO THE
DIGITAL TRAFFICKING OF THE
MATERIAL- ON THE NET SO AGAIN
REPEAT TRAFFICKING ONE MIGHT SAY
OVER AND OVER AGAIN- WHICH IS A
BIG PART OF THE PROBLEM UNDER SB
FOUR THIRTY FIVE. IF THE
MATERIAL IN WHICH THE VICTIM IS
DEPICTED HAS NOT CEASED
DISTRIBUTION. WITH TWO BUSINESS
DAYS- TWO BUSINESS DAYS AFTER
LEGAL NOTIFICATION AS DESCRIBED
IN THE BILL. THE VICTIM CAN SEEK
DAMAGES OF A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS THE SMALL DOUBLES TO TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS OF
VICTIM IS A MINOR. THE BILL
WOULD ALSO ALLOW A PARENT OR
GUARDIAN OF A MINOR TO BRING
ACTION ON THEIR BEHALF. IN THE
LAW THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TAKE
ACTION- BUT ONLY IN THE CASE OF
REPEAT OFFENDERS. SP FOUR THIRTY
FIVE ALSO PROVIDES INSTANCES OF
NO LIABILITY FOR THE DISTRIBUTOR
UNDER CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES.
INCLUDING IF THE IMAGE WAS
CREATED. IN AGREEMENT. THAT IT
IS FOR PUBLIC USE OR
DISTRIBUTION. TWO IF THE PERSON
POSSESSING THE IMAGE HAS
PERMISSION TO PUBLISH IT. FROM
THE PERSON IN THE IMAGE. THREE
OF THE PERSON THE IMAGE HAS NO
REASONABLE EXPECTATION OF
PRIVACY. OUR LAWS NEED TO BE
UPDATED TO INCLUDE PENALTIES
THAT MATCH THE TIMELINE AND
FINANCIAL SKILL. BUT THE
REALITIES OF THE DIGITAL AGE.
ALTHOUGH AMENDMENTS ARE NOT IN
THE BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY. I
COMMIT TO MAKING THE FOLLOWING
ADDITIONAL CHANGES TO THE BILL.
A NUMBER ONE AND THERE WHAT TYPE
OF CONDUCT THE BILL SEEKS TO
ADDRESS. NAMELY LIMITING THE
BILL TO DISTRIBUTION OF
ACTIONABLE MATERIAL- THE WORD
OBTAIN FOR EXAMPLE- WILL BE
STRICKEN TO ADDRESS FIRST
AMENDMENT CONCERNS INCLUDING
THROUGH CAL THROUGH CLEAR COURT
TESTED DEFINITIONS AND
NECESSARY. EXCEPTIONS. THREE
ZERO THE APPLICATION TO BUILD A
CERTAIN PARTIES IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS OUTSTANDING SECTION TWO
THIRTY CONFLICTS IN FOR CLARIFY
THE ONLY VICTIM OR THE GUARDIAN
IF THERE ARE MINOR CAN BRING A
CIVIL ACTION NOT ANY PERSON IN
APPRECIATE US SO MY COLLEAGUES
ASSISTING- THEY'RE LETTING US
KNOW OF WHERE THOSE AMENDMENTS
NEED TO BE A PARTICULARLY THE
LAST ONE- I VERY VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE HELP OF COMMITTEE
STAFF IN THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE- OVER THE
COURSE OF THE PAST YEAR. AND NOT
ONLY TO WORK THROUGH POTENTIAL
AMENDMENTS IN THE AMENDMENTS
THAT I SUGGESTED TODAY- BUT
ALSO- IT TO HELP US JUST
GENERALLY NARROW THE BUILD TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS A
PROSPECTIVE LAW THAT THAT WILL
WORK PROPERLY IN THE REAL WORLD
I'D LIKE TO THINK- OF THE IN
ADDITION- THE CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S
LAW CENTER THE AUDREY POP
FOUNDATION. ENOUGH IS ENOUGH
VOTER PROJECT EQUALITY NOW IN
MANY MANY MORE WHO HAVE
SUPPORTED THE BILL TO DATE HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ISSUE
APART WITH THE AUDREY POTTSTOWN
DACIAN LET ME SEE I RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR YOUR VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS POTTER YOU US.
YES MA'AM ALL RIGHTS OF CLOSURES
. THIS AFTERNOON I'M SHEILA POT
COMPOUNDER V. AUDREY POT
FOUNDATION AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO BECOME
PART OF IT WELL. MY DAUGHTER
AUDREY CAUGHT WITH A VICTIM OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT ON SOUTH PARK
THERE TONIGHT WELL. SHE WAS
UNCONSCIOUS SHE RESTRICTED HER
CLOTHES AND PHOTOGRAPHED NAKED.
WITHOUT A LANGUAGE WRITTEN ON
HER BODY. ELECTRONIC IMAGES WERE
SHARED ON CAMPUS AND AMONG HER
PEERS. THE AFTERMATH OF THE FACT
OF THE ASSAULT INCLUDED BULLYING
ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND BY A TEXT
AND FOUND THE OFFENDERS TRIED TO
COVER UP HE CRIME. MY DAUGHTER
FOUND HER REPUTATION WAS RUINED
AND IN HER OWN WORDS THE WHOLE
WORLD KNOWS. UNDERSECRETARY FOR
JUST EIGHT DAYS AFTER THE
ASSAULT. BREACH OF PRIVACY CAN
BE DEVASTATING TO SOMEONE WHO
FEEL THEY HAVE NO CONTROL OVER
THE FURTHER DISTRIBUTION OF THE
IMAGE THAT. THE CURRENT CIVIL
ACTIONS AVAILABLE DON'T OFFER
ANY TIMELY REMEDIES TO VICTIMS
OF THESE CRIMES. BILL WOULD
ALLOW THOSE MEDIA PLATFORMS TO
REMOVE THESE IMAGES IN A TIMELY
MANNER CAN MITIGATE THE DAMAGE
TO VICTIMS. I FURTHER FEEL THAT
IT COULD DISCOURAGE THE SHARING
OF PHOTOS THAT WERE POSTED IN A
MOMENT OF ANGER OR HATE. IT IS
OFTEN JUVENILES THAT MAKE THESE
MISTAKES THAT CREATE LIFELONG
DAMAGE TO THEMSELVES AND OTHERS
. BY ENACTING THIS LEGISLATION
WE COULD CREATE ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR REMOVAL AND POTENTIALLY SAVE
LIVES. I SUPPORT THIS BILL IN
THE INTEREST OF PRESERVING
PRIVATELY AND SAVING YOUNG LIVES
LIKE MY DAUGHTERS. I HOPE YOU
WILL AS WELL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. BEFORE WE- HAVE THE NEXT-
PERSON TESTIFY I NEED TO
ANNOUNCE THAT DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE
CHAIRS MEANS TO TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED EQUAL AMOUNT OF TIME
ALLOW TO PRIMARY WITNESSES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
ALLOWED TO PRIMARY WITNESSES
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL
EACH PRIMARY WITNESS WILL BE
ALLOWED TO SPEAK FOR. TWO
MINUTES- THANK YOU MISS PART FOR
OBSERVING THAT ALL THOSE WISHING
TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME. THEY'RE
AFFILIATION AND THEIR POSITION
ON THE MEASURE- WE ALSO HAVE- I
BELIEVE- ONE OTHER WITNESS IS
THAT CORRECT MR CORTESE CENTER
CORTESE. YES WE SHOULD HAVE ONE
OTHER WITNESS AVAILABLE BUT-
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT- THAT I'M
WRONG ABOUT THIS ALL RIGHT-
LET'S LET'S TURN IN TERMS OF
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT LET'S
TURN TO THE SENATE GALLERY OF
ANYONE IN THE SENATE GALLERY AND
SUPPORT. I SEE ONE PERSON
STANDING IN THE GALLERY AND
SUPPORT GO AHEAD. THANK YOU. FOR
THAT. I THINK THE MICROPHONE MAY
NOT BE ON SO WE MAY NEED TO DO
THAT ONE MORE TIME. MOLLY
SHEEHAN AT THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU- EXCELLENT
JUST EXACTLY AS WE'D HOPED NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT WHO ARE HERE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBER. THERESA BRENNAN
FROM THE RIGHT TO LIFE LEAGUE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY SISTER
LEONE FROM FROM THE DIOCESE OF
SACRAMENTO AND WE'RE AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
THE SAME GALLERY WHICH IS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT I SEE ONE
OTHER PERSON APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE. SUSAN ARNALL FROM
THE RIGHT TO LIFE LEAGUE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU- ANYONE ELSE
IN THE SENATE GALLERY WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT- I. HAVE IT
LET'S SEE. ANYONE WISHING TO
TELL TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
IN SUPPORT- MODERAOR IF YOU
WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE. WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB OR
FOUR THIRTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AT THE END ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE TWO LIGHTNING
HE'LL LINE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS SHARON AND NOW
I'M AN ADVOCATE ME ANTI
TRAFFICKING MOVEMENT AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AT SPEED FOUR
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
. THANK YOU BYE TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS LISA CAUGHT C.
E. O. OF THE ARTERY POPULATION I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ARE
THERE ANYONE ANYONE ELSE WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT SEEING NO ONE
IN THE GALLERY- MODERATE THERE
IS NO ONE ELSE ON THE LINE WILL
NOW MOVE TO THOSE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION- ALL RIGHT
I BELIEVE OF DYLAN HOFFMAN WITH
TECHNIP WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. MR HOFFMAN ARE YOU
AVAILABLE ON BY PHONE. I AM IF
YOU CARE ALL RIGHT THIS DROP AND
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN SENATORS AD DYLAN
HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF TECH THAT
AND WE ARE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
TO SP FOUR THIRTY FIVE. AT THE
END OF THE NATIONAL BIPARTISAN
TECHNOLOGY TRADE ASSOCIATION I
ADVOCATED FOR THE INNOVATION
ECONOMY UPFRONT WITH STATE
LEVEL- I FIRST WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR RECOUNTS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE- WE RECEIVED-
ABOUT THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
FROM THEIR OFFICE I'M STILL IN
THE PROCESS OF PREPARING
PRODUCTS. APPRECIATE HIS
WILLINGNESS TO WORK ON THIS
ISSUE- UNFORTUNATE THIS TIME
WE'RE STILL OPPOSE THE BILL IN
PRINT- AND THERE IS A NUMBER OF
SERIOUS CONCERNS. OUR MEMBERS
WERE TO REMEMBER CHILD SEXUAL
ABUSE MATERIAL AND REVENGE PORN-
EXCHANGING NOT ALLOWED. ON OUR
OUR PLATFORMS- HOWEVER WE
BELIEVE THANK YOU FOR THIRTY
FIVE WHICH FRUSTRATE ONGOING
EFFORTS TO IDENTIFY AND REMOVE-
THAT'S THE GENERAL BUT THAT'S
REQUIRED BY FEDERAL LAW AND
EMPLOYMENT. BY INDUSTRY BEST
PRACTICES. FIRST THE BILLS OKAY
TREE- TROUBLE BE USED TERROR THE
PAIR AND WITH PORN. AND BANNER I
EVEN THIS DECEMBER FOR HANDLING
DUE TO HIGHLY SENSITIVE.
STATUSES PUNCH. AND FOR THE
REQUIRED- EXAMPLE THE BILL
REQUIRES ALL COPIES OF THE
ACTUAL MATERIAL SHOULDN'T BE
DESTROYED OR RETURNED TO OPERATE
US. RETURNING CCM EVEN SO THE
VICTIM WOULD BE A TOTAL CARD-
THE STRANGERS THAT WOULD
SIMILARLY VIOLATED FEDERAL FORTY
ONES WHICH ALSO REQUIRE
PRESERVATION. DEPARTMENT BUT
WOULD ALSO CRITICALLY AND
EFFORTS TO DETER AND REMOVE ON.
RIGHT HANDED PITCHER.
ADDITIONALLY THE TWO DAY WINDOW
TO JUST OR RETURN ACTUAL
MATERIAL THEY'RE INTENDED TO
INSPIRE QUICK ACTION COULD HAVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
CURRENTLY THE BILL REQUIRES
COMPANIES JACKSON TWO DAYS
NOTICE- FROM THE VICTIM FACE
SIGNIFICANT PENALTIES HOW ARE
COMPANIES RESPONDING TO YOUR
REPORT COMPILING OF CONTENT IN
TIME OF POSSESSION FROM NATION
OF VERIFY THE IDENTITY OF THE
RECORDER. AS WELL AS I DID APPLY
AND REMOVE THE OPTIONAL
MATERIAL. FURTHERMORE OUR
COMPANY TO GET CHANGE TRYING TO
DISCERN IF THEIR CONTENT WAS THE
PRODUCT OF COLLISION OR ANOTHER
CRIME AND DETERMINE WHETHER THE
SUBJECT IN THE VIDEO OR IMAGE
WAS VERY. CALIFORNIA ALSO CRIME
DIFFERENT YOU CAN. AN SHE DOES.
ADDITIONALLY THE TWO DAY ONE
LIKE RESULT IN- OVER A MOBILE
CONTENT AND THEREFORE. SPEECH MR
MARTYRDOM YOU- BAD ACTORS THANK
YOU SIR. THANK YOU MARK- I
BELIEVE MR DAVID HOROWITZ IS
ALSO. HEARING TO TESTIFY YEAH I-
TELECONFERENCE IN OPPOSITION
WITH THE MEDIA ACTION. THANK YOU
MR CHAIR AND I WILL- I WILL GO
QUICKLY- THANK YOU MANY
OPPORTUNITIES JUSTIFYING THIS ON
THIS IMPORTANT BILL BEFORE THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE MEDIA
COALITION IS AN ASSOCIATION THAT
PROTECTS THE FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS TO THE MAINSTREAM
CREATORS AND DISTRIBUTORS OF. OF
CONTENT- WE APPRECIATE THE
SPONSOR AND THE LEGISLATORS
LEGISLATORS LEGISLATURES
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PUBLICATION
OF CERTAIN PHOTOS WITHOUT
CONSENT- THE HARMFUL PUBLICATION
BUT WE THINK THIS BILL. STILL
GOES TOO FAR WE REMAIN FOR NOW
AT LEAST. RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED.
WE DID SUBMIT A MEMO IN
OPPOSITION- EARLIER BUT I'M
GONNA DO WHAT I'M GONNA SPEAK
ABOUT IS THE BILL AS PUBLISH THE
AMENDED VERSION IS PUBLISHED. BY
JANUARY THIRD WE THINK THERE ARE
TWO IMPORTANT CHANGES THAT WERE
MADE IN AND WE APPLAUD THEM
APPRECIATE THEM THE ADDING THE
EXPECTATION OF PRIVACY ELEMENT
TO THE EXEMPTION FROM LIABILITY
FOR EXPECTATION OF PRIVACY OR
FREEIMAGES AND TAKE IN A PUBLIC
PLACE AND ALSO THOSE. RELATED TO
A MATTER OF PUBLIC CONCERN WHICH
OFFERS SOME PROTECTION. FOR THE
NEWS MEDIA PARTICULAR. AGAIN
WHILE WE SUPPORT THESE CHANGES
WE DO REMAIN- OPPOSE IT THIS
TIME- PURCHASES A CONTENT BASED
RESTRICTION ON SPEECH WE THINK
IT'S VERY URGENT YOU KNOW VERY
ESSENTIAL THAT IT BE DRAFTED
SPECIFICALLY AND CAREFULLY TO-
FIRST AMENDMENT WE THINK THERE
ARE SEVERAL. KEY PROBLEMS AT THE
FIRST IS THE LACK OF DEFINITIONS
OF KEY TERMS NUDITY SEXUAL IN
NATURE AND ALTER ALL ON DEFINING
COULD. COULD REALLY BE
INTERPRETED VERY BROADLY OR
NARROWLY DEPENDING ON DIFFERENT
CORDS- THERE'S A LACK OF AN
ADEQUATE OR EVEN ANY KNOWLEDGE
STANDARD IN THE PUBLICATION.
KNOWLEDGE AS TO WHETHER THE
IMAGES WERE OBTAINED HOW THEY
WERE OBTAINED OUT THEY WERE
CAPTURED- WHETHER IN FACT THE
PERSON AND I CAN SEND IT ALL IF
IT'S A IF IT'S AN INNOCENT
REPUBLICATION OF AN IMAGE NOT
BEING AWARE THERE WAS NO CONSENT
IT LACKS ANY INTENDS OR- TO HARM
ELEMENT- AND WE BELIEVE THE
NOTICE PROVISION IS UNCLEAR AND
CONFUSING. TO THE NOTICE GO TO
THE PUBLISHER OF THE PLATFORM.
THANK YOU MISS OUR LET'S SEE.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU MR. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT- OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION HERE IN THE SENATE
GALLERY I SEE NO ONE MOVING TO
THE MICROPHONE- LET'S NOW TURN
TO- THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE QUEUED UP TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO. SB
FOUR THREE FIVE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO ADD BEER FOR THREE FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THAT SAYS ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT EIGHT COMMENTS THANK YOU
WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY EIGHT
PEOPLE HAS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. AT LEAST WENT THIS
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE MOTION
PICTURE ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. THIS IS MARK POWERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA BROADCASTERS
ASSOCIATION- WE OPPOSE THE BILL
IN ITS CURRENT FORM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON OF THE
COMMITTEE BUT A OUR SOCIETY
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION- IN OPPOSITION- WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY ONE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON AND THAT MEANT THAT A
GRAPPLING REMAINING AT THE. TIME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
A LETTER PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS DAVID SAW THE SECRETARY
DALTON'S TO LABOR'S NOT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN FACT
OPPOSITION SP FOUR TO FIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS BRING A
ROSTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA CABLE
AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE MEASURE IN PRINT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BYE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EACH IT MAKES
THE BILL FROM THE FREE SPEECH
COALITION WE ARE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE MEASURE AS WRITTEN. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU BYE FORTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS THE LAWN AT ANY I AM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE ADULTS
PERFORMING ARTISTS GUILD WE ARE
EIGHT PACK A MEMBER OF ADULT
PERFORMER AND WE STAND IN
OPPOSITION OF THE S. P. THIRTY
FOUR THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
BEVERLY MAY I APOLOGIZE I'M WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MASSAGE THERAPY
COUNCIL I AM SUPPORTED SB THREE
THIRTY FIVE I WAS NOT ABLE TO
GET IN ON THE SUPPORT LINE. ALL
RIGHT I THINK YOU MEAN FOR
THIRTY FIVE BUT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. ALL RIGHT
IF THERE ARE NO OTHER COMMENTS
EITHER IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION LET'S TURN TO THE
FLOOR- COMMENTS ON THE FLOOR I
SEE CENTER WHAT COUNTS HIS
MICROPHONE UP CINEMA CASKEY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I NOTICE
IT'S MUCH OF THE OPPOSITION
INDICATED THAT THEY WERE OPPOSED
TO THE BILL AND PRINT. THEY
TALKED ABOUT. NAKED AND SEXUAL I
HAVE A COPY OF THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS ARE DATED ONE TEN
TWENTY TWO AND IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT. ALL ALL
REFERENCES TO NAKED AND SEXUAL
HAVE BEEN DELETED AND- REPLACED
WITH OBSCENE I DO HAVE YOU BEEN
READING IT QUICKLY HAVE I MISSED
ANY OF THAT. ACTUALLY ON THE-
THANK YOU FOR SHARING THANK FOR
THE QUESTIONS OR WHAT BECAUSE
HE- BUT THE GOAL WITH SP THIRTY
FOUR THIRTY FIVE CURRENTLY AS OF
WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT- ON
JANUARY TENTH THIS DIVIDE-
VICTIMS. THE REMEDY THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE THE CIVIL
REMEDY BUT WHILE COMPLYING WITH
LEGAL PRECEDENT BUT USING OF THE
SUPREME COURT'S DEFINITION OF
OBSCENITY WHICH YOU KNOW YOU'RE
QUITE FAMILIAR WITH AS AN
ATTORNEY UNDER MILLER V.
CALIFORNIA- THAT IS NOT
PROTECTED SPEECH BY THE FIRST
AMENDMENT- AGAIN BY DEFINITION
AND- BY YOU US SUPREME COURT
PRECEDENT. AND SOLD TO CLARIFY
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IN
TERMS OF THE TYPE OF IMAGES WITH
GUNS DIRECTLY TO THE SUPREME
COURT'S. IN THIS DEFINITION OF
OBSCENITY SAYS AS REPLACEMENT
FOR THAT LANGUAGE- THERE'S- LET
ME STOP THERE BECAUSE I THINK
THAT I THINK I SEE THAT'S THAT
DEFINITION IS CAPTURED IN
AMENDMENT NUMBER NINE WHICH IS
IN. SECTION THREE LARGE CITY I
GUESS MY QUESTION GOES TO
AMENDMENT NUMBER SIX OR ONE OF
MY QUESTIONS IS. IT LOOKS IS
THAT FOR PURPOSES OF THIS
SECTION IT READS TO THE CIVIL
ACTION SHALL NOT SHALL NOT BE
BROUGHT AGAINST AN INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDER OR AN ONLINE
SERVICE OR INTERNET WEB SITE.
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS FOR
PUBLISHING REPUBLISHING CONTENT
CREATED BY THIRD PARTY UNLESS
THE INTERNET PROVIDER ON LINE
SERVICE. OR INTERNET WEBSITE
EXPLICITLY ENCOURAGE SOLICITED
AND INDUCED A THIRD PARTY. TO
DISTRIBUTE THE ACTIONABLE
MATERIAL. I DON'T KNOW I GUESS
MY QUESTION IS THAT. IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT THAT THE- CHECK WOULD
NOT I DON'T KNOW WHAT WOULD FALL
IN THERE WHAT WHAT WOULD CHECK
NEED TO DO TO ENCOURAGE. OR
INDUCE A THIRD PARTY TO
DISTRIBUTE THEM THAT THE PAPER
IF THEY WERE JUST WILLFULLY.
WILLFULLY WHICH IS PUTTING
THINGS ON THE INTERNET WITHOUT
REGARD WITH THAT. EXCLUDE THEM
FROM A CIVIL CAUSE OF ACTION
THE- CENTRE CORTESE HOPE YOU
KEEP THAT QUESTION IN MIND FOR
JUST A SECOND I WANT TO CLARIFY
SOMETHING- A NEW SERVER KELSEY
REFERRED TO AMENDMENTS THERE
THERE ARE. NO AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE ACTUALLY ON THE FLOOR- AS I
UNDERSTAND IT AND SENATOR
CORTESE CAN RESPOND TO THIS THAT
CENTER CORTESE IS COMMITTED TO
DO CERTAIN THINGS AND IT'S NEXT
COMMITTEE- AND SO THAT THERE'S
NO. MISUNDERSTANDING AMONG
MEMBERS OR THE PUBLIC THAT THAT
THESE ARE NOT CURRENTLY
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE IN PRINT TO
BE CONSIDERED BY THE BY THE
COMMITTEE. THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION CENTER CORTESE YOU KNOW
FOR APPRECIATE THE CLARIFICATION
AND- WANTED TO SAY THAT. VERY
VERY CLEARLY. SHOULD ABSOLUTELY
COMMITTED TO THE NEW LANGUAGE-
CITING SUPREME COURT CASES
REPLACEMENT LANGUAGE- SO THAT'S
A THAT'S AN ABSOLUTE COMMITMENT
TO CROSS THOSE AMENDMENTS GOING
FORWARD- IN. SECTION TWO THIRTY
FEDERAL SECTION TWO THIRTY IS
REALLY. THE OTHER ISSUE BESIDES
THE FIRST AMENDMENT THAT
REQUIRES NAVIGATION WHEN YOU'RE
TRYING TO COME IN AND PROTECT
VICTIMS LIKE WE'RE TRYING TO DO
WITH THIS BILL CENTER WACO SKI-
IN. RECENT CASE LAW. PUBLISHED
OPINIONS- YOU KNOW SITE FAIR
HOUSING COUNCIL SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY VERSES ROOMMATES .COM-
SAYS VERY VERY SPECIFICALLY IN
IN IN THAT RULING. THAT THAT
LANGUAGE THAT YOU JUST READ A
REGARDING INDUCEMENT- SORT OF
THE PROMOTIONAL NATURE OF ONLINE
PLATFORMS THAT ARE INDUCING
FOLKS- TO BRING CONTENT FORWARD-
IS- IT HAS BEEN. RULED IN THAT
CASE- TO NOT BE PROTECTED UNDER
SECTION TWO THIRTY THAT SECTION
TWO THIRTY DID IN FACT
CONTEMPLATE A MORE PASSIVE-
INTERNET BACK IN THE DAY. WHERE
THE KIND OF PROMOTIONS THAT WE
SEE. WITH ONLINE PLATFORMS TODAY
WHICH ARE- ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO
PAY A FEE AND UPLOAD CONTENT.
REALLY DIDN'T EXIST UP BACK IN
THE IN THE DAY WHEN SECTION TWO
THIRTY WAS WAS CREATED BY OUR
UNITED STATES CONGRESS SO SINCE
THAT TIME THE COURTS HAVE. HAVE
FINALLY. BEGUN TO- IF YOU WILL-
BRING FORWARD RULINGS- THAT
START TO PARSE OUT OF WHAT
HAPPENS IF THAT INTERNET
PLATFORM ISN'T. ACTUALLY PASSIVE
IT ISN'T JUST THE PUBLIC SQUARE
IT IS ACTUALLY A COMMERCIAL
PARTICIPANTS IN THE PROCESS IN
AND THEN AGAIN- AT LEAST
ACCORDING TO THIS MOST RECENT
CASE- THAT IS NOT PROTECTED. IN
THEREFORE WE'VE GONE MUCH LIKE
WE DID WITH THE SECURE SPRING
COURT LANGUAGE ON OBSCENITY JUST
LIFTED UP LANGUAGE STRAIGHT OUT
OF THE PUBLISHED OPINION- AND WE
ARE COMMITTED TO PUTTING THAT IN
THE BILL- WHICH IS A PRETTY
SEVERE LIMITATION ON THE BILL
FRANKLY COMPARED TO WHERE IT
WAS. IN PRINT JUST A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO. OKAY I'LL LEAVE IT
THAT RESEARCHERS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH BECAUSE HE I MEAN LET ME
CLARIFY A FEW THINGS HERE FIRST
WE'LL SEND A QUICK EASY I KNOW
YOU WORK QUITE A BIT ON THIS
BILL. AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
EFFORT I THINK THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT IS OF GREAT IMPORTANCE TO
CALIFORNIANS AND I KNOW THAT
THAT WE ARE SOMEWHAT CONSTRAINED
BY FEDERAL LAW HERE BUT TO THE
EXTENT THAT THAT WE CAN. DO WHAT
WE CAN HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE CAN
AND SHOULD- YOU READ THE
ANALYSIS IS LAID OUT IN THE
ANALYSIS THERE ARE SOME CONCERNS
WITH THE BILL- WITH RESPECT TO
THAT INTERPLAY BETWEEN THE
FEDERAL LAW SECTION TWO THIRTY
AND WHAT WE CAN DO HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- OF. THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT YOU AND I
HAVE HAD OUR RESPECTIVE STAFFS
OF HEAD. I KNOW YOU BIG
KNOWLEDGE THAT AND- I'M
CONCERNED WITH PASSING A BILL
THAT DOESN'T HAVE ALL THESE
ISSUES ADDRESSED HERE. BUT I
KNOW YOU'VE COMMITTED YOU'VE
COMMITTED AND AS IS I THINK
CENTER WHAT CALCULUS TRADED.
THAT YOU'VE DONE WORK TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THESE CONCERNS- CONCERNS
CONCERT BUT WITH RESPECT TO
NEARING NARROWING THE TYPE OF
CONDUCT. THE BILL SEEKS TO
ADDRESS NAMELY LIMITING THE
BUILD A DISTRIBUTION OF ACTION
WITH MATERIAL. ADDRESSING THE
CONSTITUTIONAL CONCERNS.
INCLUDING CLEAR DEFINITIONS AND
CERTAIN EXEMPTIONS AND
EXCEPTIONS THERE ARE THE
APPLICATIONS OF THE- HE'S IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS. OUTSTANDING
SECTION THIRTY ISSUES INCLUDING
LIMITING LIABILITY FOR ONLINE
SERVICES AND PLATFORMS TO WHERE
THEY HAVE. EXPLICITLY ENCOURAGE
SOLICITED OR INDUCE THE THIRD
PARTY CONTENT CREATOR TO
DISTRIBUTE. THE ACTUAL MATERIAL
I JUST WANT TO GET YOUR RESPONSE
TO THAT CENTER CORTESE. YES
AGAIN WE'RE COMMITTED TO- TO
ACTUALLY- CROSSING THOSE MAMMOTH
SPRING FOR THOSE AMENDMENTS-
MISTER CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE YOU
- COVERING THOSE- HISTORY CITING
THOSE SO THAT I CAN COMMIT TO-
TO THAT SPECIFIC DIRECTION GOING
FORWARD. AND HE AND FRANKLY IT'S
IN OUR INTEREST TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE BILL IS OPERATIONAL IN
AND WORKS AND IT DOESN'T SET
PEOPLE UP FOR FAILURE THROUGH
THE LGAL SYSTEM AND IN ORDERTO
DO THAT- THOSE CHANGES WOULD BE
HAVE TO BE MADE- IN ADDITION
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION ANOTHER PROCEDURAL
ISSUES THAT WAS BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION JUST THIS MORNING-
THAT WE NEED TO GET A LITTLE
MORE CLEAR. ON WHO HAS STANDING
IF THE INTENT IS THAT VICTIMS
AND ONLY VICTIMS HAVE STANDING.
YOU KNOW TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE NEW CIVIL ACTION CREATED
UNDER UNDER THIS BILL BUT WE
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT'S
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR IN THE BILL- SO
WE'LL KEEP WORKING ON THOSE
KINDS OF ISSUES SO THAT THERE'S
NO UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
THANK YOU I THINK THAT THIS. IS
A- PIECE OF WORK THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT WE MAY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE IT AGAIN HERE
AND IN SENATE JUDICIARY SO THANK
YOU SIR CORTESE FOR THOSE
COMMITMENTS. OTHERS WISHING TO
COMMENT I SEE SENATOR WIENER'S
MICROPHONE UP CENTER WINNER. IF
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN- THESE ARE
MUCH LOUDER THAN THEY USED TO
BE- AND I WANT TO THANK THE-
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT. ISSUE THE IDEA OF-
PEOPLE HAVING- SEXUAL IMAGES AND
VIDEOS OF THEMSELVES- POSTED
WITHOUT THEIR CONSENT MAYBE YOU.
DIDN'T EVEN REALIZE THAT. THAT
THE VIDEO OR THE- OR THE PHOTO
EXISTED AT ALL IT'S POSTED- AND
I AGREE THAT. THERE CURRENTLY IS
NOT ENOUGH IN TERMS OF REMEDY TO
GET. THIS MALICIOUS. ARE REALLY
DESPICABLE. OUR CONTENT- DOWN.
AND GET IT DONE QUICKLY- AND SO
I FULLY SUPPORT WHAT THE AUTHOR
AND THE SPONSORS. ARE TRYING TO
DO HERE. AND I COMMEND THEM FOR
TAKING ON WHAT IS A VERY VERY
THORNY DIFFICULT ISSUE AND WE-
HEARD ABOUT THE SORT OF THORNY.
ISSUES AROUND A CALL IN THE
FIRST AMENDMENT AND AROUND. A
FEDERAL LAW- AND I KNOW THAT THE
AUTHOR WILL BE WORKING TO
RESOLVE. THE ISSUES ON THE
SPECIFIC- CONCERN THAT I HAVE
WHICH I'VE SPOKEN TO THE AUTHOR-
ABOUT HAS TO DO WITH- THE IMPACT
OF THE BILL ON SEX WORKERS AND
PEOPLE WHO ARE. MAKING THEIR
LIVING- ONLINE AND AS A TOLL OF
PERFORMERS- AND- THE CONCERN IS
THAT WITH- THERE'S A HUGE
INCENTIVE FOR PLATFORM SYSTEM TO
REMOVE. CONTENT IF COMPLAINTS
ARE FILED- AND- WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S A WHOLE ARMY OF. RIGHT
WING ANTI**** PEOPLE WHO RUN
AROUND JUST FLOODING EVERYTHING-
BECAUSE OF THE HEAVY PENALTIES
AND THE DIFFICULTY OF-
ASCERTAINING WITHIN TWO DAYS OF
SOMEONE HAS OCCURRED HAS
CONSENTED. ON YOU COULD SEE SOME
OF THE SEX WORKERS IT'LL
PERFORMERS BE. HARMED AS A
RESULT I THINK THAT THAT'S A
CONCERN- AND SO IT'S GONNA BE
TOUGH FOR ME TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY- I WILL SAY THAT I HAVE
SPOKEN TO THE OPPONENTS. OF THE
BILL- SOME OF THE OPPONENTS OF
THE BILL WHO WE WORK WITH ARE
REGULARLY- AND ALSO- WHO ARE NOT
CATEGORICALLY OPPOSED TO THE
BILL THEY THEY ALSO WANT TO-
ADDRESS DID REALLY REAL HARM
THAT THE AUTHOR IS TRYING TO GET
I THOUGHT A CATEGORICAL
OPPOSITION- THEY WANT TO SEE
SOME. CHANGES IN THE AUTHOR HAS
ALSO EXPRESSED TO ME THAT HE'S
ABSOLUTELY WILLING TO WORK WITH-
AND I'VE COMMITTED AT ALL I TRY
TO FACILITATE- THOSE CONNECT
THEM WITH- A WAY I CAN THE
COMING MONTHS- AND SO I
ANTICIPATE THIS BILL WILL BE
MOVING FORWARD TODAY- BUT LIKE I
SAID IT'S TOUGH FOR ME TO
SUPPORT IT. IN THE CURRENT FORM
GIVEN SOME OF THESE CONCERNS-
BUT I AM VERY MUCH HOPE THAT
THIS COULD TO THE POINT WHERE I
WILL BE ABLE TO THROUGH THE
OPTICALLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER- ANY OTHERS WISHING TO
COMMENT OR HAVE A QUESTION.
SEEING NO MICROPHONES RAISED. UP
ONLINE WE HAVE A- QUESTION OR
COMMENT. FROM A SENATE SENATOR
STERN GO AHEAD SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- MY
COMING THROUGH OKAY YOU ARE- CAN
I JUST GET SOME CLARITY BEFORE.
WE GET TO THE VOTING PORTION
HERE I DON'T HAVE A- AND
ANYTHING SPELLED OUT WHAT IS
BEING COMMITTED TO IN THE FUTURE
I HEARD THE COLLOQUY BETWEEN.
CENTER WHY CASKEY AND- THE
AUTHOR- THE AUTHOR WOULD MIND
CLARIFYING- YEAH WHAT WHAT WHAT
IS THE ANTICIPATED. ED CHANGES I
APPRECIATE SORT OF THE- YEAH A
LITTLE BIT THE DETAIL WAS GIVEN
ABOUT TRYING TO MAKE THE
MECHANICS WORK OF A CIVIL REMEDY
THROUGH- THROUGH THIS CHANGE
FROM. DAY TO OBSCENITY ARE THERE
OTHER ELEMENTS BESIDES THAT.
SWITCH TO OBSCENITY. IF I'M
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN-
SECRETARIES YOU DO WANT TO
ADDRESS THOSE IN YOUR CLOTHES OR
WOULD YOU PREFER AT THIS POINT
LET ME SEE IF I CAN DO A QUICK
SUMMARY I KNOW WE'RE GETTING
CLOSE TO THE CLOSE BUT- JUST IN
CASE THERE'S ANY FOLLOW UP- I
APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH SENATOR
STERN PARTICIPATING IN THE
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS THAT YOU-
THAT YOU AUTHORIZED- MISTER
CHAIR DURING A RECESS IN. OF I
KNOW THEREFORE HE'S QUITE
FAMILIAR WITH THESE ISSUES
AROUND THE SECTION TWO THIRTY
AND SOME OF THE FIRST AMENDMENT
ISSUES THAT WERE DRESSES.
PURSUANT TO YOUR OWN QUESTION-
IT AT THAT HEARING CENTER STORE
AND WE'RE- YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
FACT THAT OBSCENITY IS NOT
PROTECTED SPEECH UNDER THE FIRST
AMENDMENT- WE REALLY WANTED TO
GO RIGHT TO THAT DEFINITION TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NEARLY
TEARING THE BILL IN THAT REGARD.
UGH WHEN THE ISSUES BUT NUMBER
ONE THE BILL NARROWS WHAT TYPE
OF CONDUCT THE BILL SEEKS TO
ADDRESS NAMELY LIMITING THE BILL
TO DISTRIBUTION OF ACTIONABLE
MATERIAL- DISTRIBUTION NOT.
PASSIVE FOR EXAMPLE. A TWO
ADDRESS COST. CONCERNS CLEARER
DEFINITIONS AND NECESSARY
EXCEPTIONS THAT WOULD INCLUDE-
THE EIGHT THE OBSCENITY LANGUAGE
IN MILLER VERSUS CALIFORNIA THAT
I TALKED ABOUT A MINUTE AGO- NO
LIABILITY FOR DISTRIBUTORS UNDER
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES TYPICALLY
MANY OF THOSE WOULD BE-
PROTECTIONS FOR. OUR CLASSIC
NEWS- SERVICES WHICH- MAY OR MAY
NOT END UP WITH IMAGES- WITHOUT
CONSENT- FOR EXAMPLE WITH NO
EXPECTATION OF PRIVACY. AND THEN
A MEMBER SUBSCRIBER THE LANGUAGE
IN SECTION ONE A. RELATING TO
MAKING IN OBTAINING THE TO FIND
ACTIONABLE MATERIAL. STRIKING
THE WORD MAKING WILL PREVENT A
SITUATION WHERE DEFENDANT CAN
FILE A COUNTERSUIT. IF A
PLAINTIFF ORIGINALLY MADE THE
MATERIAL- IF SOMEONE TAKES A
NUDE PHOTO OF THEMSELVES FOR
EXAMPLE AND SENDS IT TO THEIR
PARTNER WHO LATER DISTRIBUTED.
IN THE NEXT SINCE THE POSSESSION
OF CHILD **** IS ALREADY ILLEGAL
WE ARE STRIKING THE WORD
OBTAINING IN THE SECTION AS
WELL. THE DEFINITION OF ACTUAL
MATERIAL IN. SUBPART H. E. I.
ALREADY INCLUDES MATERIAL THAT
IS OBTAINED BY TRICKERY OR SUB
PROVIDERS. WERE STOLEN. AND THEN
THIRD AND LASTLY NARROWS THE
APPLICATION OF THE BILL TO
CERTAIN PARTIES IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS OUTSTANDING FEDERAL
SECTION TWO THIRTY ISSUES- YOU
ALREADY HEARD ABOUT THAT- IN THE
DIALOGUE- BACK AND FORTH WITH
SENATOR WHAT KASKI- SO THAT
PRETTY WELL SUMMARIZES WHERE
WE'RE AT AND I JUST INDICATED
THAT WE CERTAINLY EXPECT THERE
WILL BE. AT LEAST SOME
PROCEDURAL- SHE IN TERMS OF
REMEMBER- THAT NEED TO CLARIFY.
EXACTLY WHAT THE LIMITATIONS ARE
AND WHO CAN BRING- WHO CAN-
BRING A CAUSE OF ACTION IN THE
FIRST PLACE. MMHM THANK YOU- THE
CENTER SERVES IN SANTA CRUZ
BEFORE WE MOVE FORWARD JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S CRYSTAL
CLEAR THEY'RE NOT AMENDMENTS
BEING CONSIDERED BY THE
COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME THAT THAT
YOU AND I HAD A COLLOQUY ABOUT
YOUR COMMITMENTS TO DO CERTAIN
THINGS AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD
BUT I DON'T WANT TO CREATE ANY
CONFUSION THAT THERE THAT THE
BILL IS ACTUALLY. EITHER AMENDED
OR THAT WE ARE VOTING ON THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THAT'S CORRECT
RIGHTS AND ACCORDING TO THIS
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT IN OUR WHAT I
JUST READ THROUGH IS JUST AS A
SUMMARY OF DRAFT AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE ARE NOT ON THE FLOOR TODAY A
BETTER COMMUNITY BY THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU- SENATOR STERN DIDN'T
INTERRUPT WE FINISHED NO NO I'M
TRYING TO DIGEST HERE- THAT WAS
A LOT SO I TRIED TO TAKE NOTES-
LOT OF MOVING. TO THIS BILL I
APPRECIATE THE GOOD FAITH
EFFORTS IT DOES MAKE THE VOTE.
COMPLICATED THOUGH BECAUSE I AM
. YEAH I GUESS I'M VOTING ON THE
BILL BEFORE US HERE- BUT- OKAY
FOR THE HYPOTHETICAL OR THE-
INTENDED- CHANGES IN THE FUTURE
CAN I JUST GET ONE. I GUESS ONE
POINT OF CLARIFICATION I WASN'T
SURE WHEN YOU WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT MAKING OR
OBTAINING YOU THERE WERE TWO
DIFFERENT MAKING IT OBTAINING AS
YOU REFERRED TO- I KNOW WE'VE
ADDED ISSUES IN IN MY BACKYARD
WHERE- NUMBER CONGRESS WAS.
TAKEN DOWN ESPECIALLY FOR SOME
REVENGE PORN- ENDING DOCKS BY
HER NOW EX HUSBAND AWFUL. AWFUL
SITUATION- THAT CAME OUT THROUGH
THE PRESS INITIALLY- AND THEN
SORT OF KEPT GOING FROM THERE
PUBLIC FIGURE OBVIOUSLY SO. I'M
YOU KNOW SORT OF EVEN HIGHER
CONSTITUTIONAL STANDARD GET BAD
BUT I'M JUST I'M CAN YOU GO CAN
YOU JUST TOUCH THAT PULL IT ONCE
MORE IF YOU DON'T MIND MY
INDULGENCE MISTER CHAIR IF
YOU'RE- MISTER IF YOU IF YOU
DON'T IF YOU'D RATHER NOT GET
INTO THE SORT OF HYPOTHETICAL
DETAILS TOO. I'LL DEFER TO YOU
AND TO JUST TAKE THE BILL AS IT
IS SO I DO I DEFER TO HOW YOU
WANT TO PROCEED HERE. IN IN THE
KNOW ME JUST FOR ONE SECOND
CENTER CORTESE YES- YOUR YOUR
POINT'S WELL TAKEN CENTER STERN
CENTER CONTAINS IF YOU COULD
ADDRESS THOSE. ISSUES BRIEFLY
OR- TO THE EXTENT THAT THESE ARE
NOT AMENDMENTS THAT THESE ARE
COMMITMENTS TO AMEND THE BILL-
BEFORE IT HEADS TO ITS NEXT
WE'LL GO TO APPROPRIATIONS NEXT
DOESN'T MAKE IT CLEAR THAT HE'S-
SO THE REASON SOME OF THIS
LANGUAGE DOWN SAYS ISLEY. AS IT
DOES- IN IN RIGHTFULLY SO- IS
THAT- THESE ARE TRAPPED
AMENDMENTS THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT
ON THE FLOOR FOR A VOTE TODAY
THEY ARE COMMITTED TO BUT
THEY'VE BEEN WELL VETTED-
THROUGH THE LEGAL PROCESS HERE-
THAT WE GO THROUGH THE STATE
CAPITAL SO. THE WORD UP TEAM I
MENTIONED IT TWICE BECAUSE ONCE
IT HAS A IT'S A WORD OF
SIGNIFICANCE WITH REGARD. TO
CHILD **** BEING ILLEGAL THE
CRIMINAL CRIMINALLY ILLEGAL SO
THAT THAT WORD DID NOT WORK IN
THE BILL AS WE WENT BACK AND
LOOKED. AT IT WITH- WITH LEGAL-
HERE AT HER IN THE CAR. THE
DIDN'T TO BE OUT. AND THEN
OBTAIN. ASIDE FROM MINORS THE SO
FROM CHILDREN- WAS WAS. WE DEEM
TO BE TOO IF YOU WILL PASSIVE OF
A- A WORD TO BE IN THE BILL
RELATIVE TO A VICTIMIZED ADULTS-
WHICH WOULD MEAN A THIRD PARTY-
HYPOTHETICALLY THIS IS A REAL
HYPOTHETICAL BUT HYPOTHETICALLY.
THAT TURNS UP ON IN THEIR INBOX
SOMETHING THAT THEY DIDN'T
INDUCE SOLICIT REQUEST OR OR
ANYTHING ELSE- BUT BY OPENING
THEIR INBOX OBTAINED- HE- A NON
AUTHORIZED ADULT IMAGE- THAT IS
NO LONGER A ACTIONABLE UNDER
THIS BILL THAT'S WHY WE TOOK THE
WORD OUT YOU KNOW RELATIVE TO
THE BROADER POPULATION SO IT'S
KIND OF IN A SENSE TAKEN ON TWO
CONTACTS AND THAT'S WHY I
MENTION IT TWICE I APOLOGIZE FOR
THE CONFUSION. RT THANK YOU
SENATOR DAISY SINISTER. MR IF I
COULD JUST WRAP UP I APPRECIATE
ALL THE FEEDBACK TO THE AUTHOR-
AS I SAID TOUGH VOTE- IF I DO
END UP SUPPORTING US TODAY IN.
THIS POINT. I DO ONE EIGHT YEAH
I GIVE THE AUTHOR IS CLOSER A
CHANCE TO WORK- WANT TO-
EXPRESSED MY RESERVATIONS AND
SORT OF. YEAH I TEND TO BE ONE
OF THOSE LEGALIZED SO I'D REALLY
LIKE TO. SEE THIS FLESHED OUT
BEFORE WE TAKE ANY AUTHORITATIVE
FINAL VOTES- BEFORE THE FLOOR SO
WITH THAT EXPECTATION AND TRUST
IN THE AUTHOR- OPEN TODAY TO
MOVING FORWARD AND AT THE
DISCRETION OF THE COMMITTEE HERE
SO THANK YOU FOR THANK YOU FOR
BEING DEALT. THANKS THANK YOU
SENATOR STERN OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE- IN
SENECA DAYS I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
THE BILL IF YOU ARE A PERSON OF
YOUR WORD I KNOW THAT TO BE A
FACTOR AND- IT MY VOTE IS
PREMISED UPON THE FACT THAT THAT
YOU ARE GOING TO LIVE UP TO
THESE COMMITMENTS AS I KNOW YOU
WILL SELL. THANK YOU- WITH NO
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- IS
THERE A MOTION- I'M SORRY WOULD
YOU LIKE TO COMPOSE AND RECORD
DAYS. YES I DO I WOULD IN- LET
ME SAY THANK YOU AGAIN- I DON'T
KNOW HOW MANY OF THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE I KNOW HOW HARD
THE COMMITTEE STAFF WORKED- THE
STAFF THIS COMMITTEE TO GET US
THIS FAR- INVENT FOR ENOUGH
HOPEFULLY FOR YOU TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY AND GET IT OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND YOU HAVE SO
YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT THAT
THOSE- DETAILS THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT TODAY. IN THESE DRAFT
AMENDMENTS- WILL BE PUT FORWARD
IN THE PROPER FORM BEFORE
THERE'S ANY KIND OF A FINAL VOTE
US OF- THE CALIFORNIA SENATE WHO
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHTY IS THERE A MOTION. SEARCH
FOR CLUES ABOUT ALL RIGHT THEN
SHE CANCELED YOU CALL THE ROLL
SURE THIS IS THE US SENATE BILL
FOUR THIRTY FIVE BY SENATOR
CORTESE- AND THERE'S A MOTION BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE RE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG- HI. AM
BERG I BURGESS. GORGEOUS NOT
VOTING PROBABLY IT'LL BE DOCILE
GONZALEZ. CONSEILLERS SP FOR
THIRTY FIVE QUID TASTY I.
GONZALEZ I HURTS BERG HERTZBERG
I OWNS JONES NOT VOTING LAYERED
LAYERED I STERN. STERN IS B. FOR
THIRTY FIVE CORTESE I. STERN I
WAKE HOUSEKI. BY CAL SKI NOT
VOTING. WINNER. I MEAN THEY'RE
NOT VOTING- YOU HAVE THE- YOU.
PUT IT ON CALL WE DON'T. YOU
HAVE A FIVE EYES SO FAR ALL
RIGHT WE'LL PUT THE BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU SENATOR DAISY. NEXT WE
HAVE- SENATOR SKINNER WHO'S BEEN
WAITING PATIENTLY S. B. THREE
ZERO ONE.
THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
MEMBERS- THIS IS BILL SB THREE
OH ONE WHICH DEALS WITH ONLINE.
RETAIL THEFT USING OUR ONLINE
MARKETPLACES SO I WANT TO START
WITH THAT I AM ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS WHICH
REMOVES THE PREEMPTION CLAUSE
THEY CREATE A NEXUS TO SALES IN
AND INTO CALIFORNIA. OF THE
WHICH ADDRESSES THE INTERSTATE
COMMERCE ISSUE AND CLARIFYING AN
AMENDMENT THAT CONSUMER REPORT
FEATURE IS FOR SUSPICIOUS
ACTIVITY OF THIRD PARTY SELLERS
. SENATOR SKINNER JUST FOR
AVOIDANCE OF DOUBT THOSE OF THE
AMENDMENTS ON COMMON FIVE ON
PAGE TEN ANALYSIS YES THEY ARE
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. YOU'RE
WELCOME. SO- WHAT I WANTED. WE
HAVE SEEN LOTS OF PRESS REPORTS
ABOUT RETAIL THEFT BUT WHAT
WE'RE REALLY SEEING IS A GROWING
NUMBER OF ORGANIZED CRIME RINGS
WHO ARE ENGAGED IN VERY-
ORGANIZED IN LARGE SCALE RETAIL
THEFT. IN THERE SO THESE ARE NOT
THE TYPE OF- STEPS THAT ARE
THEN- YOU KNOW FENCING OUT OF A
FLEA MARKET OR- YOU KNOW THE
BACK OF A CAR WHATEVER. INSTEAD
MANY TIMES WE ARE SEEING THAT
THEY ARE USING ONLINE
MARKETPLACES TO IN EFFECT FENCE
THE STOLEN GOODS. AND IT IS
ESTIMATED THAT MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED BILLION IN STOLEN AND
COUNTERFEIT ITEMS ARE SOLD ON
ONLINE MARKETPLACES ANNUALLY.
THIS IS HARMFUL NOT ONLY TO
RETAILERS BUT ALSO TO CONSUMERS
BECAUSE CONSUMERS THEY DO NOT
HAVE THE KID THE PROTECTIONS
RELATED TO THOSE GOODS WHEN THEY
ARE- STOLEN WHETHER IT'S HEALTH
PROTECTIONS OR OTHERS- THE
PURPOSE OF SP THREE OH ONE IS TO
HELP COMBAT THE SALE OF STOLEN
GOODS ON ONLINE MARKETPLACES. BY
PROVIDING HIGHER STANDARDS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND IDENTITY
VERIFICATION FOR SELLERS WHO USE
SUCH MARKETPLACES SO REQUIRE
SELLERS WITH OVER FIVE THOUSAND
A YEAR IN SALES TO ANNUALLY
REPORT VERIFICATION INFO TO THE
MARKET PLACE- FOR EXAMPLE BANK
ACCOUNT NUMBER BUSINESS TAX
DOCUMENTS CONTACT INFORMATION.
AND IT REQUIRES THE PLATFORMS TO
PROVIDE A LINK FOR CONSUMERS FOR
REPORTING POTENTIAL FRAUD. OF OR
SALE OF- BEST STOLEN OR
COUNTERFEIT GOODS AND IT
PROHIBITS SELLERS FROM ENGAGING
IN SALES IF THEY FAIL TO PROVIDE
VERIFICATION AND I'D LIKE TO ASK
MY WITNESSES MARGARET LAST SEEN
FROM THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION. AND CHRISTINE'S
ORDERED TO BURY WHO IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
PROSECUTOR'S ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER AND IN THE SAME GROUND
RULES APPLY THIS BILL AS OTHERS-
EACH SIDE WILL HAVE AN EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT WITH TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES EACH HAVING
TWO MINUTES. FOLLOWED UP BY
THOSE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION JUST
GIVING US THEIR NAME THEIR
AFFILIATION AND THE POSITION ON
THE BILL SO- MISS CLASS IF
YOU'RE AVAILABLE. PLEASE PROCEED
. THANK YOU. CHAIRMEN ARE ASKING
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION WILL
PLEASED TO SUPPORT SB THREE ON
ONE. THANK YOU YOUR SCANNER
SCANNER PRINTER MAKING SPENCER
AND HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE. THE RECENT RISE
IN ORGANIZED RETAIL CRIME IS
DRIVEN BY MULTIPLE FACTORS ONE
OF THE KEY UNDERLYING CAUSES THE
RELATIVE EASE WITH WHICH KEYS IN
ORGANIZED RETAIL CRIME RINGS CAN
SELL STOLEN GOODS OR ONLINE
MARKETPLACE ACCOUNT. EVEN
COUNCIL NOW OVERSEE RINGS BEHIND
BEHIND PHONY UNVERIFIED BUSINESS
NAMES AND OPEN UP A GLOBAL
MARKET ABOUT SUSPECTING
CUSTOMERS. WITHOUT THE
LIMITATIONS IN SENTENCING ITEMS
IN PERSON OUR C. BECOMES EVEN
MORE PROFITABLE. INVESTIGATORS
BUSTING OVERSEEN WORKS LIKE
FINDING. HELP ON MULTIPLE ONLINE
MARKETPLACE. FOR MORE THAN A
DECADE RETAILER AND SHOT LET. TO
TURN CRIMINAL. ON MARKET PLACE.
SOME OF THE HAVE BOMB SOME PLACE
HAVE BEEN. INCREASED THEIR THE
TURKOMAN BECAUSE- ON THE SITE
HOWEVER THIS ACTIVITY IT
UNFORTUNATELY STILL PREVALENT
WITH XCELERATED GROWTH IN BULK
ONLINE RETAIL IN ORGANIZED
RETAIL CRIME INDUSTRY WIDE
STANDARD IF NEEDED IN LAW. SB
THRILL ONE MORE COMPLEX THREE
SIMPLE BUT IMPORTANT THINGS IT
WILL PROVIDE CONSUMERS WITH
CLEAR VERIFIED INFORMATION ABOUT
THE INTERNET SELLERS. DETER
INDIVIDUALS SEEKING DEFENSE
STILL NINE ANSWER COUNTERFEIT
ITEMS USING ONLINE MARKETPLACES
BY ELIMINATING THE ABILITY TO
CONCEAL THEIR IDENTITY AND
PROVIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT THE
ABILITY TO CONTACT OWNERS ONLINE
ACCOUNT MAY BE CONFUSED OR
COUNTERFEIT PROPERTY. WHAT
HAPPENED TO THE FEDERAL SOLUTION
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE IF
CONGRESS FAILS TO ACT IN THAT
CURRENT SECTION WE ENCOURAGE
CALIFORNIA POLICY MAKERS SHOULD
TAKE A LEADERSHIP ROLE AND
PROTECT CONSUMERS BY PASSING
THIS BILL. THIS IS ONE IMPORTANT
STEP IN CURBING ORGANIZED RETAIL
CRIME. I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS
HONESTLY THREE A LAND. THANK YOU
MISS CLASS STEEN ALL ARE ON THE-
IS- MISS CHRISTY SO TO BURY.
MISSILE BERRY ARE YOU AVAILABLE
. YES THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN. RIGHT
I'M CHRISTINE SO THERE'S A VERY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
PROSECUTOR'S ONLINE THE
CALIFORNIA AND THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY THAT WE WORK WITH ALL
PRIORITIZED INVESTIGATION AND
PROSECUTION OF RETAIL ORGANIZED
RETAIL. IN THE- FOR THE GOVERNOR
C. H. P. TASK FORCE WAS LAID BY
REGIONAL INVESTIGATIONS THAT
ORIGINATED IN AFRICA AT THE AGE
. WHAT THESE INVESTIGATIONS
SHOWN THAT LARGE SOPHISTICATED
OPERATION ARE BEHIND SOME OF THE
MOST EGREGIOUS. BUT PERSONALLY
HE CAUGHT ON VIDEO STEALING FROM
THE STORE IT'S OFTEN A SMALL
PLAYER IN A MUCH LARGER MUCH
MORE LUCRATIVE SCHEME THE PEOPLE
TRULY PROFITING AND DIRECTING
THE OPERATIONS ARE PEOPLE
THANKING THE STOLEN GOODS AND
RESELLING THEM OFTEN FROM BEHIND
A COMPUTER SCREEN. IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO DA'S OFFICE
PARTICIPATED IN THE MULTI AGENCY
IN. ADDITION I'M COVERING
SELLING FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY IN STOLEN GOODS YOUR
ONLINE MARKET PLACE. THERE'S A
TOTAL OF FIFTEEN MILLION
INSTALLING PRODUCTS. FOCUSING ON
THE HIGHER END OF THE PROBLEM
YIELD MUCH GREATER RESULTS. BUT
WE CAN SHRINK THE MARKET PLACE
FOR THE STOLEN GOODS WE WILL SEE
A REDUCTION IN RETAIL AFTER. A
SIMILAR APPROACH WAS TAKING A
CELLPHONE ROBBERIES BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN. WHEN WE
PROPOSED IN THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED A BILL REQUIRING. KILL
SWITCH AND BE INSTALLED UNCLE.
WE SAW A 50% READ. IN OR
TELEPHONE MY PLACE OUT. AND
PROSECUTORS WE BELIEVE IT IS
IMPERATIVE TO ADDRESS THE
DRIVERS OF ORGANIZED RETAIL.
INCLUDING THE EASE WITH WHICH
STOLEN GOODS CAN BE ANONYMOUSLY
SOLD ONLINE. THE THRILL ONE WILL
HELP REQUIRING MICHAEL PLACES TO
COLLECT THIS INFORMATION WILL
DISCOURAGE ORGANIZED RETAIL
OPERATIONS AND WILL FACILITATE
LAW ENFORCEMENT INVESTIGATION.
COLLECTING BANKING INFORMATION
WILL ALLOW US TO COORDINATE THE
FREEZING OF FUNDS BUT THOSE THAT
ARE CONDUCTING ILLEGAL ACTIVITY
WELL THERE'S- CALIFORNIA CAN
LEAVE NOW. BECAUSE THEY NEEDED
POLLUTION IN A STATEMENT OF
DRIVING TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION
HOME TO MANY OF THESE COMPANIES
WE MUST LEAD HERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
GALLERY WISHING DOES TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE OH ONE.
SEEING NO ONE MOVING THE
MICROPHONE MADAME MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE. WISH
TO TESTIFIED. TELEPHONICALLY IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE OH ONE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF N. B. THREE OH ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT THREE IN Q. JUST ONE
MOMENT FOR THE FIRST COMMENT.
LINE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ON HIM TONE
OF TONE ADVOCATE EATEN DO LEAVE
REPRESENTING THAT CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT APOLOGY FOR THE LATE
SUPPORT I JUST STARTED
REPRESENTING THEM WE SAID THAT A
LETTER LIKE A HALF AN HOUR AGO
BUT WANTED TO MAKE SURE THE
COMMITTEE KNEW THAT THAT-
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU THE
TECHNICIAN IS IN. THANK YOU MR
ON ALL RIGHTY NEXT. THANK YOU
NINE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
. NATASHA LINDSTROM BEHALF OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I'M FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CINDY LOCKER
WITH CVS HEALTH AND SUPPORT. BUT
A MODERATE OR ANYONE ELSE ON THE
LINE YOU WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. YES I HAVE ONE MORE IN
Q. LINE FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH HI AND MICROBES IN
ON BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
HEALTHCARE PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR ALL
RIGHT ANYONE ELSE MADAM
MODERATOR IN SUPPORT. I HAVE ONE
LINER WILL BE WOMAN ONE MOMENT
FOR THAT LINE. NINE THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HAVING
EVERYTHING ON BEHALF OF THE
TARGET AND THE HOME DEPOT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT LET'S NOW TURN TO
THE OPPOSITION I UNDERSTAND
MISTER DYLAN HOFFMAN TECH NET IS
GOING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
MR HOFFMAN ARE YOU AVAILABLE. S.
RICHARD THANK YOU- DON'T OFTEN
ON THEY HAVE TO CHECK THAT OUT
AT THIS TIME WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THE BILL BUT I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS
SUBSTANTIAL AMENDMENTS- AND HER
WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE-
WE'RE PLEASED TO SEE AN
ALIGNMENT- HOUSE RESOLUTION
FIFTY FIVE UNTIL- HOWEVER WE
BELIEVE A FEDERAL SOLUTION AT
THE MOST APPROPRIATE. NORTH
KOREA ACTUALLY EXPECT MODELS-
AND WE STRONGLY PREFER FEDERAL
BUILDING TUESDAY ACTION- THAT
BEING SAID BECAUSE THOSE RECORDS
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK BILL
CONTINUE TO CONSIDER ANY
UNINTENDED HARMS TO CONSUMERS
AND SMALL VOLUME SELLERS. SPEND
THE VALORIZATION. MATTER PROVIDE
A REASONABLE IMPLEMENTATION-
AGAIN REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPOSITE MOMENTS MCCORD CHAT
WORKING OF HER OPTIONS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS ON THE BILL MCCORD
THANK YOU. I THANK YOU MR
HOFFMAN. BUT A MODERATE ANYWAY
ELSE ON PHONE AND- UP. OR HAS NO
POSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK ON F. B. THREE OH ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE IF N. ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU ALREADY THANK
YOU MODERATOR RIGHT TURNING TO
THE FLOOR I SEE NO MICROPHONES
RAISED- NO FURTHER COMMENT THE
CENTER'S KENNEDY CHEMICALS.
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR I THINK
YOU HEARD FROM WHAT USED TO BE
MARITA BEEN AN OPPOSITION THAT
THEY'RE NOT OPPOSED THEY JUST
DESCRIBE THE PREFERENCE FOR A
FEDERAL. LEGISLATION AND
CERTAINLY I WOULD WELCOME
FEDERAL LEGISLATION BUT OFTEN
TIMES A STATE LIKE CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO ACT BEFORE WE GET
FEDERAL LEGISLATION SEEMS TO
TAKE THEM A LOT LONGER IN THE
MEANTIME WE NEED TO. PROTECT OUR
RETAILERS BY DOING OUR BEST TO
LIMIT THIS TYPE OF USE OF ONLINE
MARKETPLACES FOR SELLING STOLEN
GOODS AND WE NEED TO PROTECT OUR
CONSUMERS AND WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU IS
THERE A MOTION EARLIER MOVES THE
BILL BENNETT CHIEF COUNSEL IF
YOU WOULD CALL THE ROLL. RIGHT.
I'M SORRY. JUST FOR AGAIN FOR
AVOIDANCE OF DOUBT ANYONE IN THE
GALLERY WE SHOULD TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE OH ONE
SEEING NONE OF MODERATOR AT
ANYONE ELSE ON THE PHONE WISHING
TO TESTIFY AND S. B. THREE ONE.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK OUT AND BE
THREE OH ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
TEN ZERO AT THE TIME. I HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU ALL RIGHTY.
THANK YOU MEANT TO CANCEL IF YOU
CALL THE ROLL. MOVED BY SENATOR
LAYERED. OKAY THIS IS S. B.
THREE OH ONE BY SENATOR SKINNER
THE MOTION BY SENATOR GLARED AT
THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND THEN
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS NUMBER I AM BERG
HI GORGEOUS. GORGEOUS I HAVE A
YELLOW THE RUSSELL ONE SILAS.
TEN DOLLARS SP THREE OH ONE
SENATOR SKINNER I. GONZALEZ I
HURTS BERG HURTS BERG BY JONES
JONES I LAYERED. LAYERED I STERN
. STERN SP THIRTY THREE THIRTY
ONE SKINNER NO IT'S A SPEEDY
THREE ZERO ONE SORRY AS STERN AS
T. THREE ZERO ONE SCANNER HI.
STERN I WHITE HOUSE GATE BY
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WINNER. WINNER
I. YOU HAVE A NINE TO ZERO WITH
ALL MEMBERS WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING TODAY VOTING.
THANK YOU THE BILL IS OUT ALL
RIGHT NEXT SENATOR SKINNER'S S.
R. SIXTY THREE CENTER SKINNER
CLOSURES THANK YOU SO MUCH CHEER
MEMBERS I'M- PLEASED TO PRESENT
TO YOU. OUR RESOLUTION ON THE
FORTY NINTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
U. S. SUPREME COURT RULING IN
ROE VERSUS WADE AND I'LL START
WITH ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENT THERE WAS A GOOD-
LANGUAGE ADJUSTMENT ACCEPTING
THAT- JUST USE THAT ON THE
EROTIC BUT I WILL PLEASE. JUST
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT WE ARE ON
THE SAME SHEET OF MUSIC MOMENTS
IN COMMENTS SIX ON PAGE SEVEN OF
THE ANALYSIS YES ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU. OKAY COM SO AS I MENTIONED
FORTY NINE YEARS AGO. THE US
SUPREME COURT RULED IN ROE
VERSUS WADE THAT A WOMAN HAS A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO PRIVACY
AND THAT CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
PRIVACY INCLUDES HER RIGHT TO
ABORTION. BEFORE ROE VERSUS WADE
AN ESTIMATED ONE POINT TWO
MILLION WOMEN IN THE U. S. EVERY
YEAR. RESORTED TO AN ILLEGAL
ABORTION. END EACH YEAR. AMONGST
THOSE UNSAFE ABORTIONS COST AS
MANY AS FIVE THOUSAND DEATHS.
NOW LOW INCOME WOMEN AND WOMEN
OF COLOR WERE DISPROPORTIONATELY
AT RISK BECAUSE THEY WERE LESS
ABLE TO TRAVEL TO AN AREA OF THE
COUNTRY WERE SAFE PROCEDURE WAS
BEING PERFORMED WERE LESS LIKELY
TO HAVE THEM MONETARY RESOURCES.
TO PAY FOR A DOCTOR AND DOCTORS
AND THEN EVEN WHEN IT WAS
ILLEGAL THERE WERE DOCTORS WHO
OFFERED THE PROCEDURE BUT FOR
VERY HIGH COST. SIX SEVEN. EVEN
WITH THAT PROBLEM OF THE
ILLEGALITY BEING FIXED BY THE
SUPREME COURT'S RULING IN ROE V.
WADE STATES HAVE CONTINUED TO
CHIP AWAY AT OUR ACCESS TO LEGAL
LEGAL ABORTION AARON TO THE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES THAT WE NEED. JUST A
FEW MONTHS AGO TEXAS DEALT A
BLOW TO ROW WHEN THEY PASSED S.
B. H. AND IT WENT INTO EFFECT ON
SEPTEMBER FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. IN THE LAST YEAR ALONE A
HUNDRED AND SIX RESTRICTIONS
WERE PASSED BY VARIOUS STATES
AND OVER THE LAST EIGHT YEARS A
TOTAL OF FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THREE ALMOST FIVE HUNDRED. NEW
STATE LEVEL RESTRICTIONS WERE
ENACTED. AND AFFECTING ALMOST
FORTY PERCENT. OF THE ROUTER
ACCOUNTING 440% OF ALL THE
RESTRICTIONS SINCE THE ROE
VERSUS WADE DECISION. NOW FOR
SUPREME COURT DECIDES TO
OVERTURN ROE OR ALLOWS STATE
BANDS TO REMAIN. IT WILL RESULT
IN OVER HALF OF THE STATES IN
THE US. TO BASICALLY DENY
ABORTION CARE ACCESS WHICH MEANS
THEN THAT THE POPULATION OF
THOSE STATES WOULD BE DENIED
THAT CARE. STUDIES SHOW THAT
CALIFORNIA COULD SEE A-
SIGNIFICANT CLOSE 23000%
INCREASE IN OUT OF STATE PEOPLE
TRAVELING HERE TO GET THE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES THEY NEED. AS THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS SO ACCURATELY
STATES S. R. SIXTY THREE
REAFFIRMS CALIFORNIA'S STRONG
SUPPORT FOR EVERY INDIVIDUAL'S
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO MAKE
DECISIONS REGARDING THEIR OWN
PREGNANCY AND THEIR REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH. AND IT URGES THE
PRESIDENT AND CONGRESS TO
SUPPORT OUR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
TO ABORTION SPECIFICALLY AS WELL
AS OUR ACCESS TO COMPREHENSIVE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. NOW I'D LIKE TO HAVE
MY WITNESSES MOLLY ROBESON FROM
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AND RBC FLED
FROM THE BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS TO TESTIFY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER- MISS
MOLLY ROBSON. WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD. PLANNED PARENTHOOD
ARE YOU AVAILABLE. GO AHEAD GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
HI MY REFERENCE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT THE
FEMININE MYSTIQUE TO PROVIDE
HEALTH CARE I DON'T KNOW HOW TO
HELP OTHERS. CALIFORNIA I WANT
TO THANK SENATOR SKINNER FOR HER
LEADERSHIP OFFERING THE
CONVOLUTION AND CELEBRATING
ACCORDING TO HER STORY ABOUT
HISTORIC ROE V. WADE SUPREME
COURT DECISION WHICH PROTECTS
THE RIGHT TO ABORTION IN THE
UNITED STATES. WE CELEBRATE THE
ANNIVERSARY EVERY YEAR BUT THIS
YEAR AS YOU ALL KNOW IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT THERE IS CURRENTLY A
CASE BEFORE THE US SUPREME COURT
BETTER ACTUALLY CHALLENGES THE
LEGAL PROTECTION GRANTED EN
ROUTE. PLANNING THE DECISION
FROM THE SUPREME COURT IN THAT
IT DOESN'T HAVE STATED THAT
TWENTY SIX STATES ARE LIKELY TO
BAN OR SEVERELY RESTRICT
ABORTION. I WANTED TO MENTION
ABOUT HALF OF THE STATES IN THE
UNITED STATES POTENTIALLY LOSING
ACCESS TO ABORTION WHICH COULD
IMPACT THIRTY SIX MILLION ONE
AND MORE PEOPLE WHO ARE CAPABLE
BECAUSE PREGNANT. WE'LL BE
WAITED JUST A FLOOR AND WE'RE
FORTUNATE TO BE IN CALIFORNIA
WITH LEADERS. AND BE PRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM ORGANIZATION I KNOW I
UNDERSTAND ABORTION HEALTH CARE
AND THAT ANYTHING LESS THAN
EQUITABLE ACT THAT WILL
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THOSE WHO
CANNOT AFFORD ACCESS TO CARE I
LIVE IN RURAL AREAS OF OUR
STATE. WE WILL NOT STOP FIGHTING
TO PROTECT THE RIGHT PORTION AND
WE'LL CONTINUE TO EXPAND ACCESS
BOTH FOR CALIFORNIANS AND THOSE
WHO ARE FORCED TO SEEK CARE
STATE. THANK YOU FOR
UNDERSTANDING AND THANK YOU
CHAIR FOR HEARING US TODAY- AND
BRINGING AWARENESS TO THE
PUBLISHED AND COMPARATIVE
PRODUCTS. R. S. R. SIXTY THREE.
THANK YOU ZERO- NEXT WE HAVE-
FLEW WITH THE BLUE WOMEN
WELLNESS. HELLO AGAIN MY NAME IS
DEBBIE THICK BLANKET MANDATED
THAT IN FACT THERE ARE CLASS HE
WANTED ACTION PROJECT ABOUT THE
POLICY DIRECTOR AT BLACK PEOPLE
ON IT. I'LL BE PRODUCTIVE
DOESN'T DOCTORS ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO BUILDING THE
POLITICAL AND ELECTORAL POWER OF
BLACK WOMEN AROUND CALIFORNIA
USING AN RJ FRAMEWORK. I LIKE TO
THINK THAT OUR SCANNER AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR INTRODUCING THIS
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION THAT
AFFIRMED AGAIN THAT CALIFORNIA
IS A STATE THAT HONORS AND
RESPECTS THE ABILITY TO CHOOSE.
WHEN AND HOW PEOPLE WANT TO
CREATE FAMILY. BUT IN THIS TIME
I WOULD BE REMISS NOT TO TALK
ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR MOMENT. IN
OUR STATE AND IN AND IN OUR
COUNTRY. NO MATTER WHERE CAN BE
THAT THERE WELL I LOOKED. OVER
V. WADE. WHAT ALREADY STATED
THAT OVER. OF FEET LOOK ARTICLE
TO END UP. OR COULD BARELY OF
ONE ACCESS. A MOMENT THAT WE
WILL KNOW **** LOW INCOME AND
WOMEN OF COLOR ESPECIALLY HARD.
BUT IN THESE MOMENTS IS WHERE
CALIFORNIA CAN BE A BEACON OF
HOPE. WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REIMAGINE WHAT FULL ACCESS TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE TO LOOK
LIKE. GROUNDED IN THE
REPRODUCTIVE DOCTOR THE VALUES
THAT'S IN OUR DIGNITY. THAT WE
COULD SAY THAT RELATIVE OR NOT
THE FEELING. THAT WE COULD DO
MORE TO ADDRESS THE
INTERSECTIONAL AND MULTI. FACTOR
EVE THE THIRTEEN FOLKS. EATING
BLUEPRINT NOT ONLY WHAT IT LIKE
THAT. HIM DOUBLE. ACCESS BUT
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE TO ACTUALLY
ADDRESS TWEETS AT ITS CORE.
THANK YOU ACTUALLY THE ISSUES
THAT ARE LEGAL ABORTIONS LIKE
HOUSING FAIR PAY CRIMINAL. AND
CHILD CARE. THE FULL ABORTION
MEANS THAT PEOPLE ARE CHOOSING.
ABORTION BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT
TO. BE PREGNANT AND NOT BECAUSE
WE HAVE A STATE HAVE. THE APPS
FAIL TO PROVIDE THE SPEAKING FOR
OUR MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS.
UNDERSTAND THE LAST MOMENT AFTER
THIS BODY TO LOOK AT THIS
RESOLUTION ABOUT SALLY ****
RALLY ALL. ON HOW WE CAN
CHALLENGE OURSELVES INTERSTATE
THE REDEFINED TWINS WITH DIGNITY
AFTER DINNER. THE BOLDLY AND
COURAGEOUSLY B. ON AUG
UNAPOLOGETIC IN OUR DEDICATION
ON ANY. VEHICLE THE BREAKING
PEOPLE SPEAKING LOUDLY THAT WE
WILL NOT BE SILENT WHEN THE ODDS
ARE AGAINST THE- LAW MATE WE CAN
BE THE PEOPLE THE NEXT
GENERATION CAN BE PROUD OF.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME YES.
WHILE MANY. HIGHLY. SUPPORT THIS
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
OTHERS WHICH- IN SUPPORT IN THE
GALLERY ANYONE IN THE GALLERY WE
SHOULD TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE OF MODERATOR BEFORE
WE TURN TO THOSE ON THE LINE.
FOR THOSE ON THE LINE JUST GIVE
US YOUR NAME YOUR AFFILIATION IN
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL. THOSE
IN SUPPORT MATAMATA READER.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S. R. SIXTY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHTY. ANYONE IN SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE MY MATTER MODERATOR. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT LET'S
TURN THE OPPOSITION- I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
BEGINNING WITH MYSTERIES OF
BRENNAN OF THE RIGHT TO LIFE
LEAGUE OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
MISBRANDING YOUR PRESENT HERE IN
THE CHAMBER GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN- BURKE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM THERESA
BRENNAN PRESIDENT OF THE RIGHT
TO LIFE LEAGUE AMERICA'S FIRST
PRO LIFE ORGANIZATION FOUNDED IN
CALIFORNIA IN NINETEEN SIXTY
SEVEN. I AM NOT HERE TODAY TO
SPEAK TO YOU ABOUT THE BABY IN
THE WOMB I AM HERE TODAY TO
SPEAK TO YOU ABOUT WOMEN. THE
TRUTH IS MANY WOMEN SEEK
ABORTIONS BECAUSE THEY FEEL THEY
HAVE NO OTHER CHOICE. MILLIONS
OF WOMEN ARE SUFFERING DEEPLY
BECAUSE THEY CHOSE ABORTION AND
REGRETTED IT. THEY WILL NEVER BE
ABLE TO CHANGE THEIR MIND AND
BRING THAT CHILD BACK TO LIFE SO
IF IT IS A DECISION THEY ARE
MAKING A CRISIS IT MAY BE A
DECISION THAT HAUNTS THEM FOR
EVER. LAND PARENTHOOD DOES NOT
PROVIDE COUNSELING SERVICES FOR
WOMEN DEVASTATED AFTER ABORTION
WE DO. WE SEE FIRST HAND HOW
HEART BREAKING THE AFTERMATH OF
ABORTION CAN BE. THAT MARKER
INSTITUTE STATISTICS SHOW THAT
75% OF ALL WOMEN WHO HAVE AN
ABORTION ARE AT OR BELOW POVERTY
LEVEL 75% AND THE MAJORITY ARE
MINORITY WOMEN. S. R. SIXTY
THREE IS A TRAVESTY. ABORTIONS
ARE OVERWHELMINGLY PERFORMED ON
LOW INCOME MINORITY WOMEN WHO
HAVE LITTLE OR NO VOICE.
CALIFORNIA IS OFFERING THEM FREE
OF PORTION WHICH HAS A HEAVY
DISPARATE RACIAL IMPACT RATHER
THAN GIVING THEM THE HELP THEY
NEED TO MAKE THE CHOICE THEY MAY
ACTUALLY PREFER TO HAVE THEIR
CHILD. MANY WOMEN WHO ARE
AVAILING THEMSELVES OF WHAT YOU
CALL A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT. ARE
NOT DOING SO BECAUSE THEY VIEW
IT AS THEIR BEST OPTION THEY ARE
DOING SO BECAUSE THEY VIEW IT AS
THEIR ONLY OPTION. LET'S FIX
THAT TOGETHER NOT BY EXPANDING
ACCESS TO ABORTION BY PROVIDING
HELP MOTHERS NEED TO MAKE THE
DECISION THEY MAY ACTUALLY WANT
TO MAKE NOT THE ONE THEY FEEL IN
A MOMENT OF CRISIS IS THEIR ONLY
OPTION. THANK YOU MISS BRANDON
NEXT WE HAVE. A WIN AT SILLS THE
CALIFORNIA FOR LIFE ORGANIZATION. HELLO GO AHEAD WHEN IT IT'LL-
THANK YOU MY NAME IS WHEN IT
SOLD A SERVICE A DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR LIFE I AM
CALLING TODAY FROM THE PUBLIC
SIDEWALK IN FRONT OF OUR
COUNTRY'S LARGEST ABORTION
BUSINESS PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
ABORTIONS ARE DONE HERE EVERY
TUESDAY AND WEDNESDAY AFTER
TWENTY WEEKS OF PREGNANCY WHICH
IS HAPPENING AS I SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY THIS IS A GRUESOME
BARBARICTO DAY PROCEDURE WHICH
REQUIRES THE DISMEMBERMENT AND
DECAPITATION OF THE CHILD IN THE
WORLD. S. R. SIXTY THREE WAS
CELEBRATING THE DISMEMBERMENT
AND DECAPITATION OF SO CALLED.
ONE THIRD OR INCONVENIENT HAPPY
. WOULD YOU BE SUPPORTING THIS
RESOLUTION SURELY WOMEN AND
CHILDREN DESERVE BETTER THAN
ABORTION I HAVE MET THOUSANDS OF
WOMEN WHO HAVE ARRIVED HERE
THINKING THAT THEIR LIFE
CIRCUMSTANCES WERE SO DIFFICULT
THAT THEY WERE CONSIDERING
ENDING THE LIFE OF THEIR CHILD.
YET MANY WOMEN WILL CHANGE THEIR
MIND WHEN GIVING GIVEN LOBBYING
HELP ASSISTANCE RESOURCES AND
ENCOURAGEMENT IN FACT A BABY WAS
SAVED HERE JUST A FEW MINUTES
AGO WHILE I WAS ON HOLD. JUST
THINK WITH THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
SURPLUS COULD DO TO ACTUALLY
HELP WOMEN SOLVE. THESE
OFTENTIMES FIXABLE PROBLEMS
RATHER THAN JUST PROMOTING MORE
AND MORE ABORTIONS. WE DON'T END
POVERTY BY KILLING POOR CHILDREN
WOMEN COME OUT OF THIS BUILDING
WALKING WOUNDED FROM HURTING SO
BADLY THEY ARE BARELY ABLE TO
GET TO THEIR CAR. LEAVING MANY
WOMEN WOMEN TO SUFFER FROM
DEPRESSION ANXIETY PANIC ATTACKS
NIGHTMARES DRUG ALCOHOLIC
ADDICTION AND THOUGHTS OF
SUICIDE. FOR YEARS TO COME
ESPECIALLY WOMEN WHO ARE LIED TO
AND TOLD QUOTE IT'S JUST A
COMPLEX- WE HERE FOLLOW THE
SCIENCE WELL SCIENCE PROVES THAT
HUMANITY OF THE CHILD IN THE
WOMB. EVERYONE HAS HEARD THE
SOUND OF A BABY'S HEART BEAT WE
HAVE ALL SEEN THE ULTRASOUND
IMAGES OF A BABY MOVING HER ARMS
AND LEGS HER FATE. ALL OF WHICH
ARE D. UNDENIABLY HUMAN. THE
MEMBERS OF OUR LEGISLATURE
BEYOND THAT POSITIVE LOVING LIFE
SAVING PRO LIFE PRO WOMAN PRO
SCIENCE SIDE OF HISTORY FOR ALL
OF THESE REASONS WE URGE EACH OF
YOU TO VOTE NO ON SR SIXTY
THREE. THANK YOU MISSILES ALL
RIGHT OTHERS ON THE PHONE LINE
WHO WISH TO WELL LET ME ASK IN
THE GALLERY ANYONE OF THE
GALLERY WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. TO S. R. SIXTY THREE
. SINGH NO ONE IN THE GALLERY OH
I'M SORRY ONE PERSON THE GALLERY
. I'LL GO AHEAD AND MOLLY
SHANNON THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE AND OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU. OUR GO AHEAD
MOORE SAYS THE LEONE- FROM THE
DIOCESE OF SACRAMENTO AND
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION. SUSAN AREN'T ALL
FROM THE RIGHT TO LIFE LEAGUE IN
OPPOSITION TO SR SIXTY THREE
THANK YOU OTHERS IN THE GALLERY
IN OPPOSITION SAYING NO ONE ELSE
IN THE GALLERY IN OPPOSITION
LET'S NOW TURN TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR THOSE OF YOU ON THE
PHONE. YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION
THAT A MODERATE IF YOU WOULD
QUEUE THEM UP AND LET ME KNOW
HOW MANY. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO ASK R.
SIX THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE NGO I'M SORRY
I HAVE TO ASK YOU ABOUT ALL.
THANK YOU GO AHEAD LINE FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
PENNY HARRINGTON FROM SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IT'LL JUST
BE ONE MOMENT FOR THE NEXT
COMMENT. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
LINE FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY FIFTY TWO. TONY ROSE ALL AT
THE CAPITOL RESOURCE INSTITUTE
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE. NO
ONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION I HAVE NO
. ALL RIGHT LET'S BRING IT TO
THE FLOOR. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
ON THE FLOOR SEEING NO
MICROPHONES RAISED- CENTER
SKINNER- I'M SORRY CENTER
CONSOLIDATES GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANTED TO
CHIME INTO OF COURSE EXPRESS MY
DEEP SUPPORT THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I'M NOT JUST AS A
COLLEAGUE BUT OF COURSE IS THAT
VICE CHAIR OF THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS- YOU KNOW. FORTY NINE
YEARS I THINK THAT MANY PREGNANT
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN FIGHTING FOR
THEIR RIGHTS TO BE ABLE TO
CHOOSE WHAT THEY WOULD DO WITH
THEIR OWN BODIES BUT WE'RE STILL
SEEING UP OVER THIS LAST YEAR
OVER A HUNDRED BANDS ON- THE
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOMS THAT WE
ALL- SHOULD ENJOY. AND FOR THAT
I'LL BE CERTAINLY SUPPORTING AND
I WANT TO THANK A MISPRINT
ADMITS ROPES AND AS WELL FOR
THEIR UNEQUIVOCAL SUPPORT AND
ADVOCACY THEY'VE BEEN WORKING
VERY HARD TO ENSURE THAT WE
CALIFORNIA REAFFIRMS THEIR
STANCE ON REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I.
ASK EVERYONE TO JOIN AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU CENTER
CONSOLES OTHERS SAY NO OTHER
MICROPHONES RACE NO ONE ELSE
WISHING TO- EITHER ASK QUESTION
OR MAKE A COMMENT A SINNER
SKINNER YOU COULD CLOSE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR SO I WAS
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO ENTER MY
REPRODUCTIVE YEARS. JUST SHORTLY
BEFORE WITHIN A FEW YEARS BEFORE
THE SUPREME COURT GRANTED ME AND
EVERY OTHER AMERICAN. OUR FULL
ACCESS TO OUR REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM SO I DID NOT HAVE TO
CONFRONT HER FACE THE DECISION
OF NOT BEING ABLE TO PURSUE
WHATEVER REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE I. DESIRED AND SHOWS AND- I
CAN'T IMAGINE. HAVING LIVED
THOSE YEARS WITH THAT HANGING
OVER MY HEAD SO THIS. I AM VERY
VERY PROUD TO BE A CALIFORNIAN.
I'M VERY PROUD THAT WE ARE A
STATE THAT HAS HONORED
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM AND THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO AND SUPPORTED
IN EVERY POSSIBLE WAY WE CAN
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER IS OUR
MOTION EARLIER MOVES THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT BENSHI COUNCIL
RECALLED ROLE YES THIS IS SENATE
RESOLUTION SIXTY THREE BY
SENATOR SKINNER WITH THE MOTION
BY SENATOR LAYERED THE MOTION IS
TO BE ADOPTED AS AMENDED BUT
FIRST AMEND AND REFERRED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. UMBERG I AM BERG
HI FORGES. ZERO THE DOCILE
GONZALEZ. GONZALES SR SIXTY
THREE BY SKINNER HI. GONZALEZ I
HURTS BERG HERZBERG I JONES
JONES NO LAYERED LAYERED I STERN. STERN I A SENATOR STERN COULD
YOU SAY WHAT THE MEASURE IS THIS
IS S. R. SIXTY THREE I'M SORRY.
STERN S. R. SIXTY THREE I. STERN
BY WHITE HOUSE SKI HI WHITE
HOUSE SKI I WINNER. WINNER I SO
FAR YOU HAVE. SEVEN EYES AND ONE
NO AND THERE IS- THAT MEMBERS
WHO AREN'T HERE ALL RIGHT WE'LL
PLACE THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER WE'RE GOING TO
RETURN TO- S. B. FOUR THREE FIVE
BY SENATOR CORTESE WE'RE GONNA
LIVE CALL IN JUST A MOMENT- ALL
RIGHT- IF WE COULD LIFT THE CALL
ON. S. B. FOUR THREE FIVE SURE
BENNETT CHIEF COUNSEL IF YOU
WOULD- CALL THE ROLL. HI THIS
IS- S. B. FOR THIRTY FIVE
GORGEOUS. SEVEN ZERO DEDUCTIBLE.
JONES JONES I LIKE HOW SKI
WINNER. WE HAVE ONE MEMBER
MISSING ALL RIGHT SO FAR THERE
ARE SIX VOTES HI PUT THE BILL
BACK ON CALL THANK YOU THANK YOU
RIGHT NEXT WE HAVE S. B. TWO
SEVEN ONE BY SENATOR WIENER SAID
A WINNER ARE YOU PREPARED. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN OUR COLLEAGUES
SP TWO SEVENTY ONE- EXPANDS- THE
SOURCES OF PERSPECTIVE FEDERAL
JURORS TO INCLUDE STATE TAX
FILERS TO CREATE A MORE
INCLUSIVE AND DIVERSE JURY POOL
COLORS YOU MAY REMEMBER- SEVERAL
YEARS AGO I AUTHORED AND WE GOT
SIGNED INTO LAW SENATE BILL FIVE
NINETY TWO WHICH EXPANDED OUR
STATE JURY ROLLS- TO INCLUDE THE
ENTIRE TAXPAYER ROLE. IN AND NOT
JUST LIMIT THE JURY POOL TO DMV
AND VOTER REGISTRATION FILES OF
THIS BILL SIMPLY ALSO ALLOW THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD TO PROVIDE.
TAXPAYER LIST TO THE FEDERAL
COURTS TO THE FEDERAL COURTS CAN
ALSO EXPAND THEIR JURY POOL- WE
KNOW THAT IN ORDER TO HAVE A
FAIR JUSTICE SYSTEM WE NEED A
JURY POOL THAT REFLECTS THE
COMMUNITY- THE TRADITIONAL WAY
OF DRAWING OUR JURY POOLS FROM
ONLY DMB AND VOTER REGISTRATION
OUR- VOTER REGISTRATION
DATABASES- DOES NOT CREATE A
BROAD CROSS SECTION OF THE
COMMUNITY IS NOT BROAD ENOUGH.
AND INCLUDING ALL TAXPAYERS-
WILL MAKE OUR JURY POOL MUCH
MORE REPRESENTATIVES- SO AGAIN
WE ENACTED THIS REFORM- WITH
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS OF COURSE-
FOR OUR STATE- SUPERIOR COURT-
JURIES AND THE FEDERAL COURTS
THEN CAME TO US AND ASKED TO BE
INCLUDED- BECAUSE ALTHOUGH THE
FEDERAL COURTS TECHNICALLY HAVE
THE POWER TO COMPEL THE STATE.
TO PRIVATE INFORMATION- THEY
DON'T WANT TO MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION AND THEY WOULD RATHER
ODD THE STATE SIMPLY AGREED TO
DO IT- AND THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD HAS ASKED FOR STATUTORY.
AUTHORIZATION TO DO THAT THE
BUILDER CREATE PROTECT. ARE RULE
. AS A AND SO. I CALLING
SERVICES ON IMPORTANT STEP IN
OUR QUEST FOR. FAIRER AND FAIRER
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER I VOTE.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY- IS
JUDGE WILLIAM ALSUP A SENIOR
DISTRICT JUDGE. EMMA IN THE US
DISTRICT COURT FOR THE NORTHERN
DISTRICT OF CALIFORNIA ANALYSTS
KNOW WHERE WHO IS THE DIRECTOR
OF. OPERATIONS. ALSO FOR THE
NORTHERN DISTRICT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- ALTHOUH UNLIKE
JUDGES WERE NOT REQUIRED TO MAKE
DISCLOSURES OF PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIPS I AM PROUD TO
DISCLOSE THAT THE JUDGE ALSO BUT
I WERE PARTNERS ON THIRTEEN
YEARS AGO- JUDGE ALSO FOR YOU
AVAILABLE. WE'RE GETTING HIM ON
THE LINE WITH THE BLUES NOWHERE.
ALL RIGHTS IS WELL WHEN WE GO
AHEAD WITH THIS KNOW WHERE IF
SHE'S ON THE LINE. OKAY THANK-YOU SO MUCH CHAIR AND MEMBERS- I
ENLIST NOWHERE AND I OVERSEE
JURY SERVICES FOR THE U. S.
DISTRICT COURT FOR THE NORTHERN
DISTRICT OF CALIFORNIA AND-
ALTIMETER WEINER SAID WE
APPROACHED HIM WITH GREAT
EXCITEMENT AFTER BEING THE BILL
THAT HE WAS ABLE TO PASS THE
BENEFITS REPORT THROUGHOUT-CALIFORNIA- IT WILL SIMILARLY
BENEFIT THE STATE BY MAKING A
FEDERAL JURY IS MORE CLOSELY
REPRESENT THE INCREDIBLE
DIVERSITY- CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES THAT THIS COURT AND
ALL FEDERAL COURT SIR- JUDGE
OFTEN WILL GET INTO THIS A BIT
MORE BUT I JUST WANT TO MENTION
VERY BRIEFLY BUT THERE HAS BEEN
RESEARCH STUDIES SHOWING THAT
RACIALLY. DIVERSE JURY. IN A
BROADER ARRAY. OF ISSUES IN
THEIR DELIVERY AND YOUR ACTUAL
AIR SO THAT'S ONE REASON AMONG
MANY THAT ARE. UNDER JUDGE ALL
THE LEADERSHIP AND- INCREDIBLY
DEVOTED TO INCREASING THE
REPRESENTATIVE NESS OF. OUR
JURY. WHEN THIS COURT ADDED THE
DMV LISTS TO OUR REGIONAL SPORTS
LEFT WHICH WITH THE VOTER
REGISTRATION BACK IN THE
NINETIES WE SAW AN IMMEDIATE
pREPRESENTATIONS OF BLACK LATINOS
AND ASIAN AMERICANS. IN A
QUALIFIED JURY POOL. WE RECENTLY
HAD EXPERTS. FROM THE CENTER FOR
JURY STUDIES A NATIONWIDE EATING
. CENTER FOR ACADEMIC CENTER ON
THE ISSUE ANALYZER JURY POOL AND
THEY FOUND THAT INCLUSION OF
ANOTHER FORKLIFT WOULD BRING IN
THE COURT EVEN CLOSER TO ITS
GOAL OF PROTECTING THE COMMUNITY
AND THIS IN TURN INCREASES
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN THE VERDICT
RENDERED BY OUR JURY. THERE'S A
PARTICULAR REASON WHY THE LIST
OF HIGH FILERS FROM THE FTP WILL
BE SO HELPFUL ABOUT 20% OF THE
SUMMONSES THAT OUR COURT SENDS
OUT- RETURNED UNDELIVERABLE.
HE'S UNDELIVERABLE PROMISES COME
FROM THE MORE MOBILE CALIFORNIA
NEEDS IN OUR COMMUNITY. WHO ARE
TYPICALLY RENTERS AND TEND TO BE
MORE MINORITY AND LOW INCOME.
BECAUSE MOST CALIFORNIANS ARE
REQUIRED TO INTERACT WITH THE F.
T. B. ANNUALLY WE BELIEVE THE
ADDRESSES FROM THE FTP WILL BE
FRESHER THAN THOSE FROM VOTER
REGISTRATION OR THE DMV AND I
THINK COMMUNITIES WILL BE
EQUALLY WE'LL BE ABLE TO REACH
THEM WITH PEOPLE FREQUENTLY
CONCERT I'M SORRY. OUR FINDINGS
MANY CALIFORNIANS DON'T THANK
YOU YEAH WE'RE ALL RIGHT- SHOULD
ALSO BE AVAILABLE. THE MONEY
HERE ALL RIGHT JUDGE GO AHEAD.
YES TWENTY ONE WILLIAM ALL CLUB
FROM A JUDGE. ON THE FEDERAL
COURT IN SAN FRANCISCO THE U. S.
DISTRICT COURT YEAH I'M A U. S.
DISTRICT JUDGE. AND I'M CALLING
YOU PLEASE SUPPORT AND THAT'S
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION FOR THE
BILL. THAT WOULD BE AN- I NEED
BECAUSE- OKAY THE BOTTOM HE
FRENCH I TAX BOARD FILER. THAT
ALREADY YOUR GET THE TO THE
SUPERIOR COURT. L. P. VERY MUCH
WOULD LIKE ALSO HAVE THAT INPUT
. THE TICKET. OKAY THE JUDGE
TWENTY TWO YEAR NOW THE
TELEVISION GOING OF. OWN YOU
KNOW COMMUNITY OKAY MOST
PRESSING PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE
OVER A THESE YEARS. IS MAKING
SURE THAT OUR JURY RULE IS WORK
RELATED THE. ENTIRE COMMUNITY.
WELCOME CITY AND VIRTUALLY THAT
REFLECT. THE ACT BE. CROSS
SECTION OF THE COMMUNITY. M. P.
OF COLOR ARE OPEN DO NOT GET
OURS IN THE- L. TAKE THE LEAD
FEBRUARY AT THE THAT WE USE. ARE
OUT OF DATE HE ORDERED THAT. AND
WE ALSO USE. ANYWHERE BUT
SOMEBODY CAN HAVE A GOOD QUITE
K. IN ENDED A CHANGE CRACKERS.
YEAH SO CLEARLY THE YEAH HE DID
HAVE MUCH MORE CURRENT
INFORMATION. ABOUT SOMEONE ELSE
. AND IT WOULD BE A GOD FOR US
TO HAVE THAT MORE ACCURATE. SO
HE MAY BE ABLE TO SAY. OUR
SOMEONE USED TO. BECAUSE ADDRESS
MOST RECENTLY. ELEVATED BY SHOES
THAT PEOPLE LOOK ARE. SOME TO
THE SIDE TO EVERYONE OUT. OKAY
I'LL BE. VOTING LATE.
TREMENDOUSLY STILL THE JUDGES
COURT JUST JUDGE IS WELCOME WELL
IT'S SO IT'S A PRANK LAWYER A
TELL HOW I AM TO OFF OF SITTING
DISTRICT JUDGE BUT- WE ALSO HAVE
OUR RULES SO YOUR HONOR IF YOU
WOULD JUST WRAP IT UP IN A SENSE
. I WILL DO IT. PLEASE HAVE A-
SCOTT WIENER'S. BILL THAT WOULD
EXTEND THE PRIVATE PRACTICE- DUE
TO YET D. D. HI JOE THANKS FOR
THANKS FOR OUR INFORMATION. YEAH
THE US DISTRICT COURT SORRY
THANK YOU THANK YOU JUDGE ALL
RIGHT- OTHERS IN SUPPORT AND
THERE'S AS LOOKING TO THE
GALLERY I SEE NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY WE SHOULD TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO SEVEN ONE- ON
THE PHONE LINES MADAME MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO SEVENTY ONE IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF.
SB TWO SEVEN ONE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWO SEVEN ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT LET'S NOW TURN THE
OPPOSITION- I NOTE THAT THERE
ARE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO. SB TWO SEVEN ONE
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE GALLERY
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO TWO SEVEN ONE S. B. TWO SEVEN
ONE SEEING NONE. MODERATORS OR
ANYONE THE PHONE LINE WE SHOULD
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION SP TWO
SEVEN ONE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB TWO
SEVEN ONE. THREE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU.
ALREADY THANK YOU- ANYONE WISH
TO S. COMMENT OR QUESTION CENTER
BORCHERS. THANK YOU GERMAN.
AFTER REVIEWING THIS MY FIRST
INSTINCT WAS IS THERE AN ISSUE
AND I THINK THERE IS- I WANTED
TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR- IN MY
NECK OF THE WOODS I THINK A LOT
OF FOLKS THAT- RELY ON CONVENING
JURIES IN MAKING SURE THAT THEY
ARE REFLECTIVE. OF THE COMMUNITY
HAVE A VERY DIFFICULT TIME IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. AND IF IT
HASN'T GONE UNNOTICED. THAT I AM
COLD. EVERY SINGLE STATUTORILY
AVAILABLE TIME PERIOD IN THE
ODDS OF THAT ARE JUST YOU IT
DOESN'T WORK AND THE REASON WHY
EVEN AFTER I'VE CONSULTED WITH-
WITH FOLKS IN THE CLERK'S OFFICE
IN THE COURT SYSTEM IS THAT
PEOPLE DON'T RESPOND THEY HAVE
BAD ADDRESSES AND THE POOL FROM
WHICH THEY MUST DRAW IS FAIRLY
LIMITED AND THEY JUST KEEP ON
CHURNING AND RECIRCULATED. AND
SO I THINK THIS IS PROBABLY THE
ONLY OPTION THAT EXISTS TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT WE HAVE MORE UP TO
DATE INFORMATION TO EXPAND THAT
JURY POOL BECAUSE OTHERWISE
WE'RE NOT FULFILLING THE
OBLIGATIONS THAT WE HAVE UNDER
OUR COURT SYSTEM WITH THE- A
JURY OF OUR PEERS SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS. THANK YOU
CENTER BOARD IS OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS AND WHAT CAL SKI
RESEARCHER I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE
BILL AND I'D LIKE TO NOTE THAT
NO THE GENTLEMAN FROM SANTINI
AND I ARE THE ONLY MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE THAT WERE MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN WHEN THE ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY PASSED OUT A BILL THAT
WOULD INCLUDE PERMANENT
RESIDENTS THAT ARE LEGALLY HERE
OUR COUNTRY TO BE INCLUDED IN
THE JURY POOL AND THAT
REPRESENTS ABOUT TEN PERCENT. OF
OUR POPULATION NOW IN CALIFORNIA
IT NO FOR ALEC BEST. ABOUT IT
BUT THE JURY ABOUT A POOL THAT
WE THE COMMUNITY WE LIVE IN I
WOULD HOPE THAT FOLKS WITH. WHAT
WE VETOED BY GOVERNOR FOR PAPER
IT'S IN IDEA WE WANT TO. HERE SO
I MOVED THE BILL. THANK YOU
KUDOS TO CENTER WHAT CAL
CONSIDER. ALL RIGHT- ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO COMMENT- CENTER WHAT
COUNTS HE HAS MOVED THE BILL-
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE AND WE- I
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ITEM.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT AND CHIEF
COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLL. YES THIS IS SENATE BILL
TWO SEVENTY ONE BY SENATOR
WIENER. WITH THE MOTION BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATION. NUMBER I. UMBERG
BY GORGEOUS GORGEOUS I HAVE A
ZERO. DEDUCTIBLE GONZALEZ. L. AS
SP TWO SEVENTY ONE BY WINNER HI
. GONZALEZ I HEARD BURKE.
HERTZBERG I JONES JONES I
LAYERED WHERE'D I STERN. WHITE
HOUSE SKI WHY CASKEY I MEAN-
WINNER I. SO FAR YOU HAVE EIGHT
ZERO WITH MEMBERS MISSING ALL
RIGHT PUT BILL ON CALL OUR LAST
AND FINAL BILL IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CUNNINGHAM'S BILL AB ONE
TWO SIX TWO BIT UNUSUAL TO HAVE
AN ASSEMBLY BILL BUT WE'RE
PLEASED TO HAVE A MEMBER OF THE
OTHER HOUSE HERE WITH US TODAY.
ALL RIGHT. SOME REMEMBER CUTTING
HIM THANK YOU MR CHAIR THANK YOU
SENATORS. I'M HERE TO PRESENT A
B. TWELVE SIXTY TWO AND I WILL
START BY THINKING THE CHAIR AND
HIS EXCELLENT EXCELLENT STAFF IN
PARTICULAR CHRISTIAN FOR ALL THE
HARD WORK THEY PUT INTO MAKING
THIS A BETTER WORK PRODUCT. AB
TWELVE SIXTY TWO SIMPLY PUT
WOULD PROHIBIT ANY RECORDINGS OR
TRANSCRIPTIONS COLLECTED OR
RETAINED THROUGH A VOICE
RECOGNITION FEATURE. OF A SMART
SPEAKER DEVICE FROM BEING SHARED
WITH OR SOLD TO A THIRD PARTY.
UNLESS THE USER HAS PROVIDED
AFFIRMATIVE CONSENT. THE BILL
CATEGORICALLY EXEMPT STATED THAT
IS THE IDENTIFIED AS DEFINED IN
THE CCPA. THE POWER INNOVATION
OF TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
TECHNOLOGY HAS TRANSFORMED THE
LIVES OF NOT ONLY PEOPLE IN THE
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY BUT EVERYDAY
CONSUMERS OF THESE PRODUCTS.
HOWEVER SMART SPEAKERS POSE
UNIQUE ISSUES WITH RESPECT TO
CONSUMER PRIVACY. THESE DEVICES
ARE IN OUR HOMES THERE ARE
BEDROOMS AND OUR KIDS ROOMS IN
THE KITCHEN AND BATHROOMS AND A
CAPABLE OF RECORD BOTH RECORDING
AND INSTANTLY TRANSMITTING.
RECORDINGS AND DATA TO CLOUD
SERVERS. THESE TECHNOLOGIES HAVE
CHANGED OUR WORLD FOR THE BETTER
THERE IS NO DOUBT AND THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT THERE'S NO
DOUBT ABOUT THAT. BUT THESE NEW
SAFEGUARDS THAT THIS BILL WOULD
PUT INTO PLACE WOULD ENABLE US
TO CONTINUE TO ENJOY THE
BENEFITS OF THE NEW TECHNLOGY.
WHILE PRESERVING IMPORTANT
CONSUMER PRIVACY. HOW WE WILL BE
TAKING AMENDMENTS MOVING FORWARD
. AS THE BILL MOVES ALONG IN THE
PROCESS THAT DO THE FOLLOWING
THINGS IN CONSULTATION WITH OUR
GROUPS AND INDUSTRY AND THE
MANUFACTURERS OF THESE PRODUCTS
. PERMIT SHARING OF INFORMATION
WITH A THIRD PARTY TO THE EXTENT
THAT INFORMATION IS NECESSARY TO
EXECUTE A FUNCTION OR PROVIDE A
SERVICE SPECIFICALLY REQUESTED
BY THE USER. PER PROVIDE USERS
WITH AN OPTION TO REVOKE THEIR
CONSENT FOR DATA SHARING AN
INTERFACE FOR THE DELETION OF
RECORDINGS OR TRANSCRIPTIONS AND
AN OPTION TO DO SO
AUTOMATICALLY. ALLOW
MANUFACTURERS TOPROMPT THE USER
TO CHANGE YOUR SETTINGS ONCE A
MONTH. OR WHEN THE USER ATTEMPTS
TO EXECUTE A FUNCTION THAT
REQUIRES DATA SHARING. WHICH
GIVES INCREASED CONSUMER CHOICE
. AND THESE CONCEPTUAL MOMENTS
MOVING FORWARD ALSO REMOVE THE
PROHIBITION ON FIRST PARTY
ADVERTISING. AND MAKE IT SO THAT
ONLY SELLING OR SHARING WITH
THIRD PARTIES WOULD REQUIRE THE
AFFIRMATIVE CONSENT FROM THE
USER. THAT ALSO ALIGN THE
DEFINITIONS OF SELL AND SHARE
WITH THE EXISTING DEFINITIONS IN
THE CIVIL CODE THAT WAS ADDED BY
THE CCPA. AND FINALLY THESE
AMENDMENTS WOULD ADDRESS THE
FALSE WAKE WORD ISSUE BY ALARM
COMPANIES TO KEEP RECORDINGS UP
TO FIFTEEN SECONDS LONG WHEN
REASONABLY NECESSARY TO IMPROVE
THE DEVICE. AND WITH THAT I'D BE
AT MY WITNESS. JUST NOTIFIED US
FIVE MINUTES AGO THAT HE HAD A
FAMILY MEDICAL EMERGENCY SO HE
WILL NOT BE JOINING US BY PHONE.
SO TO BE CLEAR- SO NUMBER. THERE
ARE NO PRIMARY WITNESS IS THAT
CORRECT CORRECT ALL RIGHT. ARM
ARE THERE WITNESSES ON THE PHONE
. THERE ARE NO WITNESSES SO FAR
AS I SEE. NO ONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IN THE
GALLERY ON AB ONE TWO SIX TWO-
WHEN THIS IS ON THE PHONE. OR
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE TWO SIX TWO ON
THE PHONE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
ONE TO SIX TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO APPETITE. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT LET'S NOW TURN THE
OPPOSITIONIST AND WE HAVE. TO ON
THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION MISTER
MOHAMMED FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND MR
HOFFMAN FROM TECHNET- THIS
ROBERT ARE YOU AVAILABLE. YES I
AM THE FUTURE OUR PLEASURES.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD HERE
TODAY MORNING SHOW UP ON THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND- WE MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL BECAUSE IF YOU DO
INTEND TO REGULATE THE HIGHLY
COMPETITIVE SMART SPEAKER MARKET
TO CREATE INCONSISTENCIES WITH
THE VOTER APPROVED CALIFORNIA
PRIVACY RIGHTS ACT TWENTY
TWENTY. CPR A PARTICULARLY WITH
REGARD TO THE OPT OUT PRIMARK
YOU DATA CURRENT LAW ALLOWS
CONSUMERS TO OPT OUT OF THE
FILTER DATA UNDER CPR A
REGARDLESS OF THE HARDWARE OR
PLATFORM NOT BY WHICH THE DATA
COLLECTED. HELLO THINK YOU'RE
INVITED YOU TO CONSUMER DATA
REGARDLESS OF THE DEVICE MAYBE
TWELVE TO GET. SMART SPEAKERS
ONLY IN INTO DOING IT REVERSES
THE PARENTS OPT OUT FRAMEWORK
FOR THIS LIKE A HARDWARE IN THIS
WAY AT TWELVE SIXTY TWO COULD
STILL BENEFIT FROM ON THING- THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN VOICE
TECHNOLOGY ITSELF AND HARDWARE
WITHIN THAT TECHNOLOGY IS HOUSE.
SIMILAR THERE'S ALSO A LACK OF
DISTINCTION BETWEEN VOICE
RECORDING THEMSELVES IN THE
TRANSCRIPTION- THAT THEY
RETURNED ATTACKED IN THE BILL-
THEY TREAT THEM OUT EFFECTIVELY
DEPENDING UPON THE MIDDLE TO THE
BACK OF THE PRODUCTSBEING
REGULATED HERE HAVE ONLY. ONE
FUNCTION. CONSUMERS ARE JUST
SPEAKERS ARE ARE UNDER NO. OF
WHAT THE- DO. HAVE THE GENERAL
DON'T DO ANYTHING ELSE. THE CORE
FUNCTION OF THE DEVICES IF THE
TREE. WITH AND CONSUMERS BY
DEFAULT. FOR THE PURPOSE UNDER
CURRENT LAW. CONSUMERS ALL
ENJOYED FELL OFF OUT OF THE SALE
INFO. RIGHT DELETE RIGHT THAT.
AND MORE UNDER. AT FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECT OPPOSE THE
TWELVE SIX TWO AND ACCORDING.
WITH YOU. STOP AS WE- THE
PROPOSAL. FROM THIS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MUHAMMAD FOR
OBSERVE THE TIME LIMITS THAT IF
WE WERE TO EVER GIVE AN AWARD
FOR MOST WORDS WITHIN A SPECIFIC
TIME. YOU WOULD CERTAINLY BE A
CONTENDER THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
OF MISS HOUGH MR HOFFMAN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN SENATE BILL
HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF TECHNIC-
WE'RE ALSO RESPECTED BECAUSE THE
TWELVE SIXTY TWO WE CAN
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO LISTEN TO AND
ADDRESS SOME OF OUR CONCERNS.
HAVEN'T BEEN BEEN ABLE TO
CIRCULATE THE LATEST DIMENSION
FOR MEMBERS BUT LOOK FORWARD TO.
PROVIDING THAT FEEDBACK-
SPEAKING OF THE BILLING PRINT I
THINK IT'S A FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE
WITH THE TWELVE SIXTY TWO IS
THAT IT KEEPS TRYING TO REINVENT
MANY EXPECT PRIVACY PROTECTION-
APPROVED BY VOTERS WITH PROPERLY
FOR NPR A FROM ONE TYPE OF
TECHNOLOGY- IT DOES WELL IT AT.
TECH MAN. IF YOU TOLD SIXTY TWO
SHORT FOR RESPONSE SPEAKER- CAN
ARE HAVE A RIGHT KNOW. AND WE
THE PERSONAL. POINTS FOR
TRANSFER. ADDITIONALLY AT TWELVE
SIXTY TWO COMPLEX WITH EXISTING
OPT OUT REGIME BURGERS. RIGHT
HER CONSUMER STOPPED AND-
OFTENTIMES FOR THE DEVICES.
THANKS THERE. AS MR MENTIONED IN
ANOTHER ISSUE WHICH
TRANSCRIPTION RECORD- THIS WAY
WE BELIEVE THIS ONE DR AND- THE
COMPLEX OF I'M TRYING TO COMPLY
THE BILL- AND WHILE THE TRIES TO
ADDRESS. ACT ACT BLISSFUL WAKES
REQUIRES CONSUMERS TOPPED TO
ALLOW COMPANIES TO USE. CAN
PRETTY ACCURATELY. HOW WE CAN'T
GET WHETHER A WEEK WAS ALL ABOUT
RETAINING AN ANALOG- WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING ON THIS
TECHNICAL ISSUE- IN ORDER TO
MATCH. THE VILLAGE THING AFTER
STATED INTENT. FOR THESE REASONS
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE ANY
TWELVE SIXTY TWO HERE AT THE
VICTIM. CARDS OR CONSPIRATORIAL
THE REMAINING ISSUES WITH THE
AUTHOR AND OFFICE I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MR HOFFMAN
UP BEFORE WE TURN WELL IT LET'S
LET'S TAKE OTHER OPPOSITION-
SAYING NO ONE IN THE GALLERY
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. MADAM MODERATOR. IF
WE COULD TURN TO THE PHONES.
THANK YOU YOU WISH IF IT OUT. TO
A ONE TWO SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
IF N. ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE TWO COMMON THINGS
Q. IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
THE FIRST COMMENT. OUR FIRST
COMMENT IS FROM LINE SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME OR TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON NUMBERS CHENEY HOP
WITH THE CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU MORE
WELL BEING OF THE CONSUMER
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION AND
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. BETTER MODEL YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT ALL
RIGHT- BEFORE WE TURN TO
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS FROM THE
FLOOR- THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CUNNINGHAM I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS FOR QUITE SOME
TIME YOU SPEND A LOT OF TIME
WITH OUR STAFF AND WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS. AND I ALSO KNOW
YOU TO BE A PERSON OF YOUR WORD
AND YOU KEEP YOUR COMMITMENTS
BUT JUST TO. REVIEW SOME OF
THOSE COMMITMENTS AS THIS BILL
MOVES FOR THESE ARE NOT
AMENDMENTS BE TAKEN TODAY THESE
ARE SIMPLY COMMITMENTS AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD TO. ASSUMING
IT IT MOVES OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
PREPARATIONS. THAT THE-
PROHIBITION. OF WILL BE REMOVED
ON USING RECORDINGS AND
TRANSCRIPTS FOR ADVERTISING
ENTIRELY AND THEREFORE- SUCH USE
WOULD NOT REQUIRE AFFIRMATIVE
CONSENT FROM THE USER. AND
THEREFORE IT'S SUPERSEDES AN
AMENDMENT THAT HAD BEEN PROPOSED
CONCERNING- A- MORE RESTRICTIVE
USE OF ADVERTISING IS THAT YOUR
UNDERSTANDING. THAT'S CORRECT
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU. N. ALSO
INSERTS- CERTAIN DEFINITIONS OF
SELL AND SHARE THE TRACK WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY
ACT. YES MISTER CHAIR THAT'S
CORRECT WE WANT TOTAL ALIGNMENT
BETWEEN EXISTING DEFINITIONS PUT
IN THE CODE BY C. C. P. A. IN
THE DEFINITIONS THAT ARE. USED
HERE FOR SELINGER OKAY AND THEN
ALSO ALLOW COMPANIES TO RETAIN
RECORDINGS FROM FALSE WEEKS FOR
UP TO FIFTEEN SECONDS. THAT'S
THE LENGTH OF THE ACTUAL
RECORDING- AS IS NECESSARY TO
IMPROVE THE- DEVICE IS THAT
RIGHT YES MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THAT CAME OUT OF A NUMBER OF
CONVERSATIONS AND MEETINGS OF
STAKEHOLDERS THAT SEEMS TO BE.
THE APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF TIME
FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
THOSE RECORDINGS ANALYZE THEM
PUT IN PUT THEM THROUGH. MACHINE
LEARNING DIFFERENT DEVICES TO
MAKE SURE THAT SOMEBODY IS USING
A SMART SPEAKER THAT MAY HAVE AN
ACCENT OR SPEECH MPAIRMENT OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT CAN STILL
ACCESS THE FEATURES OF THE
DEVICE. AND I'M ALSO AWARE THAT
THERE THERE'S STILL SOME OTHER
ISSUES TO WORK OUT BUT- GIVEN
YOUR COMMITMENT I I'M- GOING TO
VOTE ALL RIGHT TODAY- OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS I SEE
SENATOR BORJAS MICROPHONE RACE
AND A BOY JUSTIN AND SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU. IT SEEMS
LIKE A PRIVACY IS NEVER IN EASY
ISSUE TO TACKLE AND I WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR
SPEARHEADING THIS EFFORT FIVE
WHEN YOU WHEN I HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CHAT. I HAPPEN TO
HAVE AN ALEXA DEVICE I WAS
SHARING THIS WITH YOU YESTERDAY.
AND IT'S VERY CONVENIENT YEAH
I'M IN THE KITCHEN JUST LIKE
EVERYBODY ELSE AND I YELL OUT
YOU KNOW PLAY THIS TYPE OF MUSIC
ALEXA TURNS ON AND PLAYS THE
MUSIC. THE PROBLEM THAT I RAN
INTO IS THAT MY SON'S NAME IS A
LECCO. SO IMAGINE HOW MUCH
INTERFERENCE THERE IS IN MY
HOUSEHOLD- EVERY TIME I YELL AT
MY KID- YOU GIL ACROSS THE HOUSE
IMMEDIATELY ALEXIS STALLS OUT
REINTERPRETS AND- I NEED TO-
CHANGE ALEXIS NAME TO SOMETHING
LIKE BARBARA ROOM MARGARET OR
SOMETHING TO GET MORE PALATABLE
IN OUR HOUSEHOLD- MY FATHER'S
NAME. I BRING THIS UP IS BECAUSE. IT'S A LITTLE EERIE SOMETIMES
WHEN YOU HAVE THESE SPONTANEOUS
ANNOUNCEMENTS THAT COME THROUGH-
THE SMART SPEAKER PROGRAMMING.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE HAD
THAT EXPERIENCE ON BEFORE BOMB
OR ALL OF A SUDDEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE PRICE OF
BROCCOLI AND NEXT THING YOUKNOW- THROUGH VARIOUS MEANS YOU
FIND OUT THE BROCCOLI'S ON SALE.
AT OTHER LOCATIONS. THESE ARE
THE THESE ARE THE BY PRODUCTS OF
THIS TECHNOLOGY AND OF COURSE
PEOPLE AND INDUSTRIES- PROFIT
FROM THEM AND THE DATA SHARING
THAT GOES ALONG WITH IT- MY
FATHER IS ELDERLY. AND ONE OF
THE BENEFITS OF HAVING THIS
DEVICE IS THAT HE CAN YELL INTO
THE DEVICE. AND PLACE AN ORDER
FOR FOOD OR ASK FOR ADVICE ON
SOMETHING OR GET A TELEPHONE
NUMBER. PRIVACY IS ONE OF THOSE
SITUATIONS WHERE THERE IS A
PUBLIC BENEFIT. AND THERE IS A
PRIVACY DRAWBACK AND THERE'S A
BALANCE THERE IN SOMEWHERE IN IT
CHANGES ALL THE TIME ON IN ANY
GIVEN SCENARIO. THAT'S WHY
PRIVACY SUCH A STICKY WICKET-
WE'VE SEEN IT IN TWENTY
NINETEEN- WHEN WE WERE DEALING
WITH ALL THESE LEGISLATIVE
ISSUES IN JUDICIARY AND ON THE
FLOOR AND THEN OF COURSE THERE
AFTER PRIVACY IS ONE OF THOSE
THINGS THAT. WE SHOULD EMBRACE-
AS THE- A LEGISLATIVE SPACE
BECAUSE SO MUCH IS CHANGING SO
QUICKLY WE NEED TO KEEP UP WITH
THE GOOD ACTORS IN THOSE- THAT
MAY NOT FIT THAT BILL AS WELL. I
BELIEVE THAT- THE AUTHOR HERE IS
DOING. A YEOMAN'S JOB OF TRYING
TO CREATE A BALANCE THAT LOOKS
AFTER. THE INDUSTRY'S NEEDS.
BECAUSE THEY'RE THE ONES THAT
DANCING TO THESE TECHNOLOGIES.
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT ARE
ALLOWING A. I. TO BECOME AN
EVERYDAY COMPONENT OF OUR LIVES.
AND LORD KNOWS IF YOU'RE A
COMPARISON TO CHINA FOR EXAMPLE
AND THAT'S THE FURTHEST REACHES.
OF HOW AI IS BEING USED. IN THE
MORNING VARIOUS WAYS. WE'RE NOT
IN THAT SITUATION WE DO HAVE TO
LOOK AFTER. THE- PERCEIVED
RIGHTS IN THE CONSTITUTIONAL
PROTECTED RIGHTS THAT WE HAVE
WITH THE IDEAS OF PRIVACY IN THE
HOME. SO I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
ACTION I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL TODAY. KNOWING THAT IT IS
VERY MUCH A WORK IN PROGRESS.
THERE ARE STILL NEGOTIATIONS ARE
THAT ARE BEING UNDERTAKEN ON THE
FINE TUNING OF ALL THESE ISSUES
AND I'M VERY HOPEFUL THAT THE
AUTHOR. WE'LL CONTINUE THE GOOD
WORK THAT IS DONE. TO FIGURE OUT
HOW SOME OF THESE CAN BE
RESOLVED MAYBE SOME CAN BE BE
SOME CANNOT. BUT I THINK THIS IS
A PROCESS THAT WE NEED TO GO
THROUGH NORMALLY I DON'T LIKE
SUPPORTING BLLS THERE'S THAT
STILL HAVE SO MUCH WORK TO DO.
BUT IN THE PRIVACY WRONG I DON'T
THINK THERE'S A CHOICE. SO I'LL
BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY-
ON AND LOOK FORWARD TO WHAT. THE
CONVERSATIONS IN THE
NEGOTIATIONS YIELD DURING THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND THEN
WE'LL SEE WHAT THE FINAL PRODUCT
. THANK YOU CENTER BOARD JUST MY
CONDOLENCES TO YOUR SON ON BEING
RECORDED CHANGES FIRST NAME ALL
RIGHT. CENTER WINNER. I FIGURE
AS THE CHAIRMAN I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY- AND I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR- WORKING
ON A IT'S AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
WITH THIS TECHNOLOGY IS VERY
POWERFUL AND BRINGS A LOT OF
BENEFITS. TO PEOPLE- BUT ALSO
HAS POTENTIAL DOWNSIDES AND SUCH
DECISIONS TAKE HERE A GOOD FAITH
STOP- TRYING TO- AMELIORATE
THOSE DOWNSIDES AND I KNOW THAT
IT'S ON THE TO WORK IN PROGRESS
AND THE ALTAR IS COMMITTED TO
SOME GOOD AMENDMENTS SO- HAPPY
TO SUPPORT AND I MOVED THE BILL
. THE CENTERS FOR. PRIVACY SPENT
HUNDREDS OF HOURS IN THE CCPA
THE C. P. R. A. N. THE LIKE IN
THIS IS INDEED A VERY
CHALLENGING ISSUE BECAUSE
PRIVACY IS I'VE OFTEN SAID USED
TO BE A PEEPING TOM LOOKING OVER
THE FENCE AND TODAY. WHO KNOWS
WHAT IN TERMS OF THE TECHNOLOGY
AND WHAT KIND OF INFORMATION
THAT FOLKS CAN HAVE AGAINST YOU
I WANTED TO RAISE MY MICROPHONE
FOR A COUPLE REASONS FIRST. WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
SKETCHES OUT. FOR THE NINE
DELICIOUS SPEAKERS IN THIS ROOM
THAT'S HIS GUTS CALL ME LIKE
CRAZY HE'S BEEN ON IT HE'S BEEN
VERY DILIGENT AND I THINK THAT
<c.magenta>ATTERS- IT IS TRYING TO SOLVE A</c>
CHALLENGING PROBLEM AND I'M
HOPING THAT AS THE- PRIVACY
BOARD GETS TOGETHER MORE OF
THESE KINDS OF ISSUES ARE
OFFLOADED TO THE JURISPRUDENTIAL
FRAMEWORK THAT WILL BE CREATED
BY THE PRIVACY BOARD. RATHER
THAN IN THESE LEGISLATIVE TASKS
AND I JUST WANTED TO ECHO WITH
THE QUESTIONS AND MAKE SURE IT'S
ACCURATE WITH THE CHAIRMAN SAID
. BECAUSE AND- YOU KNOW WHAT
CAUGHT MY ATTENTION BACK AND
FORTH IN TERMS OF THESE
AMENDMENTS. I WASN'T PLANNING ON
VOTING FOR THIS BILL TODAY. AND
I DID SO BASED UPON THE FACT
THAT I WAS ASSURED THAT THESE
AMENDMENTS AS EXPRESSED BY THE
CHAIR I DON'T NEED TO REVIEW
THEM AGAIN. WE'RE GONNA BE
TAKING AN APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. AND THE LS I HEARD
SOMETHING DIRECTLY INDIRECTLY-
SEVEN MEMBER THAT IS EXACTLY
CORRECT WILL TAKE THOSE
AMENDMENTS IN APPROPRIATIONS
CORRECT ABSOLUTELY OKAY THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH AND AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR GOOD WORK
APPRECIATE. YOUR YOUR GOOD
LEGISLATOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
I SUGGEST THAT YOU CLOSE NOW.
SEVEN MEMBER CUTTING HIM ON THAT
NOTE. I HAD ANYONE ELSE NO OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS ALL RIGHT.
BUT AGAIN I WANNA THANK
EVERYBODY FOR WORKING SO HARD TO
TRY TO MAKE THIS SOMETHING THAT
WORKS AND STRIKES THE RIGHT
BALANCE I THINK THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO THESE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS I THINK
HANDLED THE FALSE WAKE WORD
ISSUE. SO THAT. YOUR SON IS A
CONFUSED FOR ALEXA FOR THE REST
OF HIS NON LIFE AS LONG AS YOU
KEEP IN YOUR HOUSEHOLD I THINK
THAT WE'VE- MOVED IN A POSITIVE
DIRECTION ON THAT ISSUE I THINK
WE DO HAVE IS THE OPPOSITION
HIGHLIGHTED SOME ISSUES TO WORK
ON. STILL WITH RESPECT TO
TRANSCRIPTION VERSES AUDIO
RECORDING NOW WE DEFINE CERTAIN
THINGS BUT I HAD A MEETING WITH
THEM TODAY AT ELEVEN O'CLOCK AND
WE MADE A LOT OF PROGRESS AND
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK
THROUGH THAT. AND AGAIN YES
SENATOR HERTZBERG THANK YOU- I
AM COMMITTED TO TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED BY THE CHAIR
IN APPROPRIATIONS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO FINE TUNE THIS I
THINK WE CAN GET THERE. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE WORLD WERE
. I ANY TYPE OF SMART SPEAKER
DEVICE AND PUT IT IN THEIR
BEDROOM THE KITCHEN INTEGRATE
THEIR HOME WITH THESE WONDERFUL
SPEAKERS- THAT THEY CAN DO SO.
WITH THE FULL CONFIDENCE. THAT
THE RECORDINGS ARE GOING TO BE-
THE RECORDINGS THAT CAN BE DONE
OF THEM WITHOUT THEIR CONSENT
AND NOT TO BE SHARED WITH THIRD
PARTIES. WITHOUT THEIR CONSENT I
THINK. THAT'S A- REASONABLE
PRIVACY BASELINE FOR ALL OF US
TO STRIVE FOR. WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NIGHT OUT
. THANK YOU- THE MOTION. WELL
I'M SORRY SENATOR HERTZBERG I'M. SEVEN WINNER MOVED CENTER ONE
WINNER MOVE THE BILL ALL RIGHT
MA'AM SHE COUNTS OF YOU CALL THE
ROLL THIS IS THE SUM OF THE
BILL. TWELVE SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CUNNINGHAM THE
MOTION BY SENATOR WIENER AND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST TO
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG HI AMBERG
FIVE GEORGIA. PORGES HI COVEY
IT'LL DID ASAL GONZALEZ. CONSOL
IS AB TWELVE SIXTY TWO
CUNNINGHAM I. GONZALEZ I HURTS
BERG HERZBERG I JONES. LAYERED
LAYERED ICE STERN. STERN HI AT
SORRY I KEEP MISSING THAT YOU
NEED TO BILL NUMBER AGAIN I PUT
YES AND NO WORRIES- THIS IS AB
TWELVE SIXTY TWO BABY CISTERN AB
TWELVE SIXTY TWO CUNNINGHAM I.
STERN HIGHWAY CASKEY HI BY CAL
SKI FIVE WINNER. WINNER HI DO.
YOU HAVE- EIGHT ZERO WITH A
MEMBER MISSING. ALL RIGHT ARM
THANK YOU WILL PUT THE BILL ON
CALL OF ALTHOUGH WE'RE GONNA
LIVE CALLS HERE MOMENTARILY-
WE'RE GONNA LIVE CALLS HERE IN-
FIVE MINUTES. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SOMEONE OVERCOMING HIM.
ALL
RIGHT ON WHAT WE LIVE CALLS HERE
AND- IF THERE'S IF THERE'S A
ANOTHER MEMBER WHO'S COMING.
THEN WE'LL WE'LL HOLD SILICEOUS
LIFT UP THE CALLS ON- AND- CALL
THE RULE. ON ON THE BILLS THAT
SURE MISSING STARTING WITH FILE
ITEM WINE SP FOUR THIRTY FIVE BY
SENATOR CORTEZ A- WITH- THE
CHAIR BOARDING UP I. GORGEOUS.
NOT VOTING GABRIELLE RUSSELL.
WHITE HOUSE SKI WINNER. IN NO NO
WE DON'T THANK YOU WINNER NO-
THAT THAT BILL HAS. ONE TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE SIX SIX SIX TWO
ONE AND EVERYONE HAS VOTED WHO
IS GOING TO BE HERE AREN'T THE
RULES OUT. SALE ITEMS HE WAS
ALREADY OUT FIVE ITEMS THREE AM
THE SENATE RESOLUTION SIXTY
THREE BY SENATOR SKINNER WITH
THE CHAIR OF THE DANG I BORE
JUST. COPY IT ALL. THE RUSSELL.
THAT BILL IS SEVEN TO ONE WITH
EVERYONE HAVING VOTED OR NOT
VOTED. SEVEN TO ONE. BILLS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR SP TWO
SEVENTY ONE BY SENATOR WIENER
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I COVEY
IT'LL HIT US SO. STERN. STERN
STERN SP TWO SEVENTY ONE WINNER
HI. STERN I. THAT'S NINE TWO
ZERO WITH ALL MEMBERS HAVING
VOTED FILLS OUT- THE LAST
MEASURE FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
A. B. TWELVE SIXTY TWO WITH- THE
CHAIR VOTING I HAVE A ZERO
DEDUCTIBLE JONES. THAT IS EIGHT
ZERO BILLS OUT. ALL RIGHT THAT
CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS OF THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WE
WILL RECONVENE UPON THE CALL OF
THE CHAIR. THANK YOU.